there's no time o clock okay what
episode is it Jenny episode 183 183
pandemic show yeah that's gonna be a
real cheerful yeah well this was like I
hadn't actually thought of doing this
one but then I don't know if it's
because you said something about
coronavirus like on one of the other
shows and somebody in the youtube
comment said oh you should do a show
about pandemics like through history and
stuff like that and I said you know what
that's a pretty good idea so I actually
shifted a few of the topics around so we
can do it this week it's a McCobb
subject it is some of my military
training and experience can't apply to
surviving an apocalyptic pandemic if
it's possible well some people just
aren't gonna make it if your health is
bad if you're a certain age groups if it
was a pandemic a real full-blown
pandemic you guys is grass you're
[ __ ] toast yeah and we're gonna get
into I mean I kind of wanted to cover
like two of the worst ones we're gonna
talk about coronavirus two will probably
do that first yeah but I want to talk
about two of the worst ones obviously
the Black Death which wasn't just one
thing it was like a series of plans
so that was happy also in many times it
did yeah yeah you know there was one the
worst like a three year outbreak but it
kept coming back and I also wanted to
talk about the Spanish flu of 1918 which
is funny because you don't hear as much
about that why don't you do about the
Black Death even though it killed either
the same or more people than the Black
Death did I guess because it happened
right around the same time as World War
one so everyone's kind of like worrying
about that you know what I mean say you
don't really hear as much about it as
you do is maybe some of the other ones
but it's pretty horrifying I was just
watching like a [ __ ] I think it was a
PBS American experience documentary
about it earlier
and they had people that you know the
the documentary was several years old
but they still had people that
remembered it and remembered like people
in there like their friends dying and
like their moms and dads and [ __ ] like
that and it was like [ __ ] up [ __ ] in
there about like oh you know that it got
so bad and like some towns in the US
that some people were telling like 12
year old kids and stuff well you know
put get on the waiting list for a coffin
Rock you know it was [ __ ] up you know
I mean so it's like I I feel like people
forget about it just kind of because
World War one was such a big horrible
thing that happened and everyone kind of
talks about that but they didn't but
they said most of the people that died I
mean the Spanish flu killed more people
than I think World War one and World War
two put together yeah you know I think a
lot of people it did it was millions in
millions I think about it is that it
didn't have a really high mortality rate
it just had a real high contagious rate
it was you know the you had oh I think
was an 80% contagion yeah and and yeah
and the conditions at the time did help
yeah like what particularly because of
the World War 1 conditions that I think
that helped it you'll see bread and get
more you'll see through these historical
cases that were talk about you know in
terms of the history of this you'll see
that society's reaction to them is very
different and how bad the art was
different depending on what time frame
it was like in the middle in the Middle
Ages a pandemic wasn't interpreted to be
the same thing as it would be today
yeah and that particular disease could
probably come back again and it wouldn't
affect people the same way I think it
probably wouldn't it wouldn't spread the
same way at all well I mean the bubonic
plague is still around yeah um but it's
but everybody knows what it is yeah and
I don't think it's an exact same strain
of a body plague they tend to kind of
get more symbiotic as they evolve I
think was a lot more lethal when it
first it was I mean it killed millions
what was it 40 million years 60 million
people something like a lot of it had to
do with cold weather in a bunch of rats
living underneath your house and that
that was a situation it was like filthy
condition yeah it was super unsanitary
situation that doesn't
just today right you're not getting
eaten plus they didn't know what was
causing it so they didn't know how to
prevent it so they were doing like a
bunch and it's kind of sad like you can
say I've medieval people they were like
dumb [ __ ] they didn't
understand like that it was a bacteria
that it brahs by a flea and you know so
maybe they should try to like you know
clean [ __ ] up they didn't understand
that they just thought it was like God
was punishing them for something and so
they didn't really know what to do so
they were like doing a bunch of dumb
they said to us seems like dumb [ __ ]
they saw things in religious terms they
did we'll talk about that later I'm not
totally convinced at buboes is bubonic
plague it's definitely not the same form
of it well there's several different
types there's bubonic plague which is
the thing that causes the big you know
growths like in your groin and your in
your armpit then you got your pneumonic
plague which is related but it has
different symptoms so there's like three
different types like I said there are
still strains of it around today but
it's very isolated pockets and they
generally know what causes it now it
does still kill people but not you know
no it doesn't wipe out like half the
population of a [ __ ] continent like
it did back in the eighteen hundreds
yeah indeed the housing situation than
the cleanliness situation isn't around
to that right so you know in some ways
it's hooray for science because like if
it because I think like the problem that
they had with the Black Death and why it
kept like recurring and [ __ ] like that
was because they didn't have any idea
they thought it was like some like
stinky air yeah and this is bacteria
you're talking about yeah and it was
bothering them the threat nowadays is
viral and a virus is a lot more
sophisticated it can just spread
person-to-person it doesn't need [ __ ]
up it because it's technically not a
living organism except it's sort of act
it's like a half a living organism yeah
that's the other organ isn't a reproduce
yeah they don't carry our metabolism as
far as we know they don't think that
it's just a piece of RNA yeah and it's
just like I accident probably some of
the first some of the first forms of
life or something kind of like a virus
I think it probably was yeah because it
seems like that's kind of like the next
building block kind it acts sort of like
a living organism but it's technically
not it's kind of like in-between so yeah
so um well probably I think I only have
one shout out this week and that is just
like I said last week did I say last
week I don't remember if I did or not
we finally got our old like behind asses
all the young people out there were like
I actually had a comment on that
somebody said we were waiting for you
guys yeah but you know I said I try to
post at least one thing every day like I
said whether it's just like a picture of
Pookie or whether it's like one of our
azazel shirts or whether it's our
whatever Jenny's under 13 o'clock
podcast I'm just Tom Ross you listen to
me there's numbers and [ __ ] on there
there's a way where you can change it
make your own name but every every one
of my selected it [ __ ] rejected it
well that's probably because it's
already taken yeah but I tried different
versions of of it you know what I mean
cuz I found it very easy mine was just
Jenny underscore Ashford and then I just
went in there I said can I just change
it to 13 o'clock podcast and the
relationship so I did maybe I could just
put that 13 o'clock something or the
other on the back of my name somewhere
13 o'clock podcasts you electric
boogaloo that's what you should call it
yeah that's like two longer types
they're probably so I think that's the
only because I don't think we had any
new patrons this week so you know I know
so I think that's the only shout I'm
glad a show man give us a like give us a
thumbs up right now share and go follow
us on our new Instagram account I know
there's no [ __ ] set of stuff on there
yet but it's like I'm trying to post
like at least one thing every day
that's entertaining in some ways so
you've been following the stuff about
the coronavirus yeah since everybody's
like trying to be all over YouTube talk
about that let's talk about that first
and then we'll get into the more
historical stuff that I researched yeah
yes time's going on what I thought it
was
more people are starting to think it's
the same thing even some people in the
government I kind of thought it was
gonna be something like an accidentally
released by a weapon or they were
messing around with it with a vaccine
possibly to a bioweapon or maybe a
vaccine against SARS or you know or you
know they already had corona
I think SARS was a type of Quran well
coronavirus is a type of is a type of
virus it's similar to SARS okay yeah
it's related and it almost all of them
like come from animals they think that
probably this strain maybe came from a
bat but they're not entirely sure yeah I
think I think now that other
universities and firms have gotten their
hands on this and looked at it they say
it's not naturally occurring virus it's
they believe it because there's there's
like these telltale marks that'll be in
a in a virus to where that you could see
where they spliced stuff into it and
it's you know we've been genetically
engineering this kind of stuff for a
long time now they have companies that
and machines that can do this and I
think it was an Indian firm and then a
university somewhere in Europe you know
I don't know maybe if you dug up that
information or not they looked at it so
far that can I can think of off a had
two of them that have looked at it and
they just say it looks very suspicious
that's just kind of like a like a budget
stuff well if some of the stuff came off
the HIV virus some of it came from other
places it looks like they were trying to
make a vaccine that's what I think maybe
it sounds plausible to me I don't think
it was a weapon maybe a vaccine for SARS
and it's rumored that there was well
want one report that I saw said that
some Chinese students up in Canada got
arrested for being spies and stealing a
vaccine from a Canadian firm that would
maybe was related to this that was just
something I heard though you know
the audience had to check that out for
themselves that they're really
interested it looks like maybe this was
this maybe the same thing that those
Chinese students stole because the
outbreak happened right around a
high-level containment area where they
actually work on [ __ ] bio warfare and
healthy autonomy and a lot of times you
hide your biological warfare programs
inside of some kind of health clinic you
know and claim that your work on the
team that's what we were doing we're
probably still doing it the Soviets
we're doing it yeah
you make a you take a you take a virus
or some kind of a viral disease and you
try to make either make it more deadly
and find a van find a cure for it you
know then it'd be kind of like fully
weaponized all that [ __ ] was highly
classified and they're not gonna really
admit to youth in the United States
isn't gonna admit to everything that
they've done in that realm
supposedly we've shut all that down but
I just can't see I can't see that as
it's true
some biotech you know privately
privately contracted biotech firms are
probably making all kinds of weird ass
[ __ ] for the government just just in
case yeah it's just in their interest to
do that kind of [ __ ] and just the timing
of the outbreak is kind of strange think
about China's losing its trade war China
was having problems with Hong Kong it
looked like the Hong Kong protesters
were winning and getting their way China
has a large population and it has a
large they have a generation that they
call the useless generation and it's
their old people that grew up under
communism they don't have any modern
skills so they're just kind of dependent
and a lot of their sit it's like it's
like a Chinese version of a Boomer it's
that same generation and evidently
they're not really adapting to well to
modern economies in the future that they
want for China and they're kind of
expensive there isn't real communism in
in in in the in China of the CCP doesn't
work that way it's more kind of like the
economy's kind of looks more like Nazi
Germany it's
like you know National Socialism where
you have a weird merger of corporation
and government working together you have
government-owned corporations inside
China that really run the show so could
be that maybe the Chinese thought that
this was a good time to one reduce the
population of old people to have an
excuse to crack down on people who are
dissident to the government it's
plausible it's plausible because most of
China's locked down right now well yeah
but I mean ok so China has had several
of these types of they had like a major
flu outbreak in 2009 they have a lot of
their viruses seem to be and this one is
so similar like a corona virus is
usually a what are they though a notic
is what they call it when it comes from
animals from an animal usually from pigs
or bats or cattle or something like that
usually the you know the the virus just
kind of passes from animal to animal and
humans can't catch it but then there's a
mutation and then it becomes you know it
becomes transferable from human to
animal so are from animal to human so
they suspect that this is what happened
because they think that the same flu
that happened in 2009 and your SARS kind
of stuff this corona virus they've
actually called it the CDC has named
it's ours - CoV - because it's so
similar the Chinese government actually
released the genome of it like pretty
shortly after it you know became clear
that it was becoming a pandemic so
several other countries have like
sequence the genome oh so they did
release it yes they pretty much I think
a month after the first case as far as I
can because information was old but
first information was that they couldn't
get it somebody else got no they
released it they released it either
early in February or late in January
alright so several other countries in
the United States has also sequenced
that genome and they have compared it to
the very few people that seem to have
got it in the US and those I think I
believe as of this morning and we're
recording this on February 15th
I think there are 15 cases in the US but
no fatalities and from what they have
compared the genome that the Chinese
government released the genome to the
you know the disease that these people
have it seems to be the same one and
like I said it seems to be very very
similar to SARS so they think that it
probably originated from one of the wet
markets yeah Wuhan did they mention any
evidence of the thing being engineered
at all no because there was actually
people in the in beside the central
government the federal government here
saying that that that they believed that
it was genetically engineered not that I
read I never saw anything like that
because they said it was so similar to
ones that had spread there before
natural that it just appears to be
another one of those because like I said
this isn't the first time this has
happened you know what it means sitting
there first rodeo with like these killer
flu viruses this is the worst outbreak
though it is it is the worst outbreak so
far it's not the same it's not the same
version of Corona that they had before
yeah it's spread fast well flus mutate
flu viruses tend to mutate very quickly
ironically the more fatal they are
usually the quicker they burn out
because they kill the people before you
can spread it that's [ __ ] up but it's
like that's kind of usually what ends up
happening is like people that get them
and they die right away like before they
can [ __ ] spread them to people and so
they a bunch of channels the doctors
talking about it and looking at the
numbers and the ones that I'm looking at
are saying that they they believe that
in some cases the person can spread this
for about 20 to 24 days and be
asymptomatic showing no sides I have
heard a symptomatic for two weeks years
yet but it's usually about seven to two
weeks yeah but some people can be start
spreading it a symptomatically within
days like two or three days after
catching it
yeah it's I've seen 2 to 14 days they
said so that's why there are quarantine
people you know if you've been to China
and you're coming back to like your
country of origin they will quarantine
you for two weeks until they see if any
symptoms yeah present themselves so the
CDC is telling everybody like hey if
you've been to this area of China
anywhere in China and you come back to
your country of origin be mad because
like you will probably be quarantined
for 14 days until we see if you have
like [ __ ] well whatever it is
man-made or not you can just look at
China's reaction and they are jumping
out of their own skin yeah although I do
have to say very serious well their
response to this and I've seen like
several kind of high ranking like you
know people that look that that look
into like disease people from the CDC
and stuff they're actually like and I'm
not sure if like the Chinese government
is lying about [ __ ] like you know maybe
they are cuz you know how they're with
the censorship and everything like that
but from what I've read everybody seems
to be like much they said it's much
better this time than the last flu
outbreak in 2009 weird like they try to
keep everything on the DL and they were
like just wouldn't give you any
information and it was like this big
huge [ __ ] and they were like hey
what's going on over there and like they
were being really cagey about it they
said at least this time they seem to be
at least like more like I said they they
were very like some people are
criticized and it's like hey you had the
first case like in you know December of
2019 it's like why didn't you tell us
about it then but it's like the thing is
this is a flu and flus are very common
so I think it takes like a little while
to get to a point where holy [ __ ] this
is a really bad flu people are dying
from and a lot of people are getting it
you know to a point where cause if you
just see one dude turn up at a clinic
and he has like a really bad flu and he
dies from it you know people might just
think well maybe he's immunocompromised
or maybe so so so I can't really fault
them for going a couple weeks it's like
to make sure that like this is like a
bad situation but the fact that they
released the genome of you know of the
virus you know they released it to the
public to everybody like everybody in
the world got it and like sequenced it
or whatever so it does seem like they're
trying to you know kind of get back it
because they got really badly criticized
in 2009 for the flu outbreak that
happened then because they were trying
to be secretive about it and like you
know keep everything clamped
down you know yes it seems very harsh to
like shut down entire cities and [ __ ]
like that but that is a pretty good way
of keeping [ __ ] from spreading farther
than it did and when we talk about the
Spanish flu from 1918 it you know even
in the United States they have the same
[ __ ] thing happened they wouldn't let
you go out of your house [ __ ] and I
can't remember if it was in Philadelphia
or box or somewhere like that like they
were making everybody wear masks you
know so you wouldn't spread it any
further
once it's making me cough one dude one
dude wouldn't wear his mask like in the
street somebody told him not somebody
told him like to put the mask on and he
wouldn't they shot him they shot him
dead like right in the street so it's
like you know it sounds harsh and
draconian but in this situation you
really have to keep it contained yeah I
mean you know you don't want it
spreading over the whole entire [ __ ]
globe yeah and then another thing is is
that China's got an economy to protect -
well yeah that's that's a consideration
yeah I mean you know all your eBay all
your eBay orders will be [ __ ]
cancelled or delayed if they don't get
that [ __ ] yeah because I think what a
lot of people I mean it's like it that
they they make all they are although our
trinkets and it's something that that
you don't really think about because you
just think oh it's a flu outbreak and
stuff like that but it has like a huge
like ripple effect on the economy and
stuff like that because it's like
there's thousands and thousands of
people in just one city that can't go to
work they can't produce you know you'll
find out later on in the show and I
imagine you everybody probably knows
this by now it's not so much the disease
that's the killer
it's the effects of the disease yeah cuz
it starts shutting down the society and
things aren't delivered to the stores
and then there's panic and chaos a lot
of stuff happens people stop going to
work yeah it's the real thing it really
does make a huge and really I'm you got
to stay home to stay alive yeah or to
stay healthy and everybody's doing it
well guess what your lights go out yeah
okay you lights go out well the dude up
the street he's running out of food
already yeah all right
she says I'm gonna go get some food
pulls out of God United States get to
God or machetes something like that and
kills a neighbor to get to get some food
to feed his children
that's how extremely yeah and that
what I mean and I feel like that kind of
[ __ ] it's like you saw this more it
wasn't quite as bad at least not in the
United States and the Spanish flu
epidemic
most people were pretty willing to like
comply with you know and they tried to
stay home but whole towns would like
[ __ ] shut down you know what I mean
so be like Katrina I think yes and you
know I helped in the Katrina thing it
was in Baton Rouge at the time there was
you know when the State Police and we
supported the cops while they were
trying to maintain at least put on the
public show of that they were trying to
control that city that city [ __ ] blew
up there are people missing to this day
and there's stuff that people will never
know about that happened down there yeah
and you know that's gonna happen anytime
you have your infrastructure
it was Mad Max for starting to crumble
you know what I mean and it's funny
because you don't really think about the
impact of I mean particularly when we
talk about the Black Death it's like the
impact of half the population of Europe
just Europe dying and and it's weird
because that actually had some positive
effects later and did serfdom and
slavery among which that's a silver
lining you know it's it's terrible that
everybody died in like such horrible
conditions it was the end of the dark
ages
it was just it had to be because it
there came a point where so many people
had died that like the wealthy people
didn't have like all these like didn't
have all these PE peons that they could
work on their land and [ __ ] like that
and they were sitting there going happy
Haitians dead right so it's like and the
the peasants quote-unquote realized that
and we're like hey [ __ ] you pay me
that's right I'm not working for you for
nothing it's like you know they know
there's not enough people around it was
like a labor shortage yeah and and the
peasants could pick up and just move to
another exactly where they could get
paid and your kingdom would work it was
all kind of land and houses free and
also there are a lot of business that's
terrible
a lot of benefits to rapid population
decline or population reduction there's
a lot of advantages to it for the
survivors I mean you could argue you
could argue this if somebody ever lets
out a pandemic that's why they're doing
it because they've I've seen a movie
like yeah because they've planned a
post-apocalyptic eliptic world in which
they will be more wealthy and freer and
more powerful than they were and yeah
that's plausible that I mean it's almost
kind of like [ __ ] chick Marilyn it was a
Charles Manson tried to do something
kind of like that he thought you could
survive a race war that he could cause a
race war and then survive it yeah how'd
that work it wouldn't work out that way
though they didn't really have a
survival skill set sanity among those
thing you thought you could just hide
all right but yeah so that was one thing
that I guess it had sort of occurred to
me but I was watching a documentary
about the Black Death earlier and they
said yeah that actually you could argue
that the black death was one of the main
you know kind of impetuses behind
impetuses is edward behind the
renaissance yeah because that kind of
like caused this new like blossoming of
it cuz people were more mobile it's like
people actually got paid for their work
like people could actually live and they
had leisure time and [ __ ] like that you
know not to the extent it's today but
better than before like you said it
pretty much got rid of the whole serfdom
system because it just wasn't
sustainable anymore because so many
people were [ __ ] dead that's kind of
why it makes you wonder you know China
might come out better after yeah after
this maybe they did let something like
this go but I don't know I I always feel
like I'm not saying that some [ __ ] isn't
like a conspiracy or some [ __ ] isn't
done on purpose cuz some [ __ ] is but
everything's a conspiracy it's not
though stuff like that it's because I I
don't know how you look what is it well
I guess that I guess because I'm really
interested in you know like evolutionary
biology and stuff like that so I
understand how much accidents yes play
this can be part of your plan like
like me the week you know everything's
alright you see this accident and then
you make a plan around that accident
right but that's still I mean that's
just that's my conspiracy you know tell
me what I've made my own thank you see
me and some other he another so it all
depends on how you want to define it
some you know for instance like out of
that movie dr. Strangelove mmm-hmm they
accidentally caused the nuclear war but
when they realized that they couldn't
they couldn't stop it they were like oh
but you know what
we can come out pretty good by little
that's just taking advantage yes that's
not a conspiracy in the sense that you
just planned all of this elaborate but
can you forget all of a sudden if you're
an outside of that group all of a sudden
you're like man they're using this to
their advantage maybe they did this
there's a conspiracy going on they're
all gonna go down in that damn hole with
all the hot women for 50 come up you
know that's what they're talking about I
think in general that's what I'm like I
said there are smaller conspiracies yeah
but like I know some people believe in
these things like world-spanning like
conspiracies and I just can't get into
that because I'm like hard to get
everybody to agree what yeah it's kind
of hard to get everybody to like on the
same page and it's hard to not have
people blab it's like everybody is an
individual you can't get two people to
agree on what to put on a [ __ ] pizza
much less how to run the [ __ ] world
I'm not saying that but it's it's
limited its limitations and they have
their own they have their own lives and
even they can't control everything
because they're like so moving off of it
and running off it but I think they do
kind of there is some evidence that they
do try to manage the situation they do
like like stopping disruptive emerge in
the emergence of disruptive technologies
like I'll see a technology start to
emerge and they like you know that it
cost us our Empire well yeah that
company then they shell and that
yeah and that has demonstrable happened
yes I mean look at like [ __ ] about you
know what was the thing about where they
didn't want to um didn't like the
[ __ ] street car companies like try to
[ __ ] with her the car companies like
bought out the Shriekers yeah it goes on
like that but
like that you know those are like
smaller conspiracies and that's just
kind of something where I think most
events that happen are contingent on
other events so I don't think that any
one person or any small group of people
can like control any of it yes you can
watch for [ __ ] like that to happen and
like take advantage of that yeah but
like I said that's not when I think of a
conspiracy I think of like some like
Spectre and they're just like in a room
and there's like we just like thought of
every little detail and we're
controlling everything I don't think
that that goes on because there's too
many things
there's too many factors that are out of
human control yeah you know what I mean
but you got on the subject of Spectre
that's James Bond I know they weren't
just they weren't really controlling
everything though they were just a mafia
that had its tentacles into everybody
and they were just that was just the
first like yeah they were just called
shadow so they can make money off of it
yeah which yeah I know
it does exist yes they do that yeah they
do that I'm just saying that like I
think a lot of times like [ __ ] that
happens and people are like oh it's this
big like it's this one big group like
the Illuminati or whatever just do
everything's gonna look more like
organized crime yeah it's more like that
yeah I believe in those come yes sure
right but you know I don't believe in
this like Oh everything that happens
like one time between rich powerful yeah
yeah everything that happens is not
because of human agency because humans
are in the grand scheme of the universe
humans are kind of pitiful so it's like
I kind of feel like there's too many
factors that are just out of our control
you know what I mean so I I feel like
you can't like build these big elaborate
conspiracies where everything is gonna
go like exactly the way you want it to
go because nothing ever does okay you
don't mean I'm just saying too many
contingencies so in that sense it's like
I don't know you know I'm not saying
it's impossible that China like released
a disease or something like that but I
just feel like it's more it's I go with
likelihood it's much more likely because
this has happened many times before I
come from a world where I was
living in an army that was run by
generals that had armies of killers who
had come up with these [ __ ] plants
two white [ __ ] out and then you
start doing it yeah I mean yeah that's
not a conspiracy no but all right but if
you were say in control of a large
company or a large country and you said
you know I have the power to do whatever
I want because I control all the
agencies if I were to release this thing
that we have a bunch of people would die
would justify a crackdown it was it
would help me win this trade war it
would be kind of like a stealth way of
getting it done yeah it would be in his
advantage now do I have proof that he
did that no yeah it looks like maybe he
didn't but then it looks like maybe he
did it's either way I'm not saying it's
impossible I'm just saying that because
of the way it looks and because this
type of thing has happened in this
almost exact way so many times before it
seems unlikely that's all I'm saying
or it could have had a bunch of times
and they saw it and they said you know
that's in our [ __ ] bioweapons
playbook sure is so but it's like the
thing about it is that you could
speculate about that although you'll
never know here's the thing we all never
and I'll talk about this on other shows
okay we did I talked about this on the
MKULTRA show which that was something
that really did happen and that was I
think was called book was called the
Warren Commission where they were
turning the [ __ ] yeah the Warren
Commission was the JFK it was the
chicken okay what was the one where they
turned turned to the intelligence
agencies upside down for a while oh [ __ ]
I'm looking for [ __ ] and that's how
MKULTRA came yeah to light and some of
the other weird [ __ ] they were doing in
Canada with the damn psycho psych
hospital yeah anyway yeah control yeah
I'm not saying that people don't do that
guys I'm just saying it's usually like
fairly small scale right fairly okay
I don't you know it's like these big
supervillain type of schemes that's hard
to pull off you know what I mean oh yeah
yeah like I've come from a background in
where we would pull off big things like
[ __ ] up a country kill millions of its
people and steal a bunch of golds also
known as Iraq you know and then give it
to the rich guys that told us to do it
all right that's pretty [ __ ] big
there and there's a little and there's a
lot of training manuals for a lot of
these kind of units you know it's not
like just some dude thinks of it that he
read about it because spies from [ __ ]
50 years ago said you know you could you
you can get a disease here's the thing
do this tip here's the thing this virus
right is now like a free source
bioweapon if you get somebody alright
who's sick you could take it from them
and give it to other people and send
them to any country that you want to the
to your enemies and launch a bio attack
on them now UK so if I was a terrorist
right now I'd be trying to look down it
would be tracking down sick of mother
for themes easier to build a bomb just
saying yeah but again I talked about
this in that other thing that if you the
most effective weapons or bombs all
right
best thing out there is a nuclear weapon
but if you use nuclear weapons on your
enemies they will know that you did it
yeah and you'll pay for it but if it's
you have a beauty of a bio weapon is
that it's deniable yeah I didn't do it
come on applause Ryan only possible
denied the [ __ ] man they've been doing
like that kind of [ __ ] like way back
even before the Middle Ages probably
what they like taking plague-ridden
bodies and like throwing them out there
and [ __ ] catapults and [ __ ] like that
ya know they knew how to do this me it's
[ __ ] up my Mac you into the worst I'm
kind of mad I kind of Mac about
Machiavellian and I'm gonna say that
there are guys that are even smarter and
more evil than me who would probably
figure out a way to use this and oh yeah
yeah I know
okay I know and I'm just gonna you're
not gonna be able to prove it that's the
nature of bio warfare that's why bio
warfare existed because you could deny
it
yeah alright and this is a pretty good
weapon because it's human to human
traditionally they were usually using
[ __ ] that involve effectors which is
like mosquitos carrying things but there
there's been a lot of problems with
bioweapons though at least the ones that
we know of you know the only real good
one they had was anthrax and you can't
use it it's not deniable people know
because everybody's like hey yeah
anthrax not that [ __ ] off yeah although
they never did catch that person that
did those anthrax attacks did they in
2001 or 2002 what everyone know but it's
an obvious bioweapon it is yeah it was
like yep that's anthrax yeah spores mold
spores I just I don't know it's it's
kind of like I feel like yeah they're
like yeah it could have been done on
purpose sure but you'll never know but
like I said I always go with some more
likely option and the more likely option
said it was can't came out on one of
those mark did it's just another one
because that's like another one they've
had like several of those even in the
past like 20 years that have come out of
those and they think that this one
because it's so similar to SARS they
said it probably came from bats it it's
because that's where starts getting
spreads quickly so far as we know the
lethality might be around 5% that's
that's the last time yeah but other
people can count at different ways all
right the people who have to get it so
bad that they have to be hospitalized
the amount of them that die is actually
about 15% so if you go into a hospital
if you get it so bad you had to go to
the hospital there's about a 15% chance
you'll die some predict that it will
probably end up being a little bit
higher as more of them die probably more
closer to 20 so if you're asked kids
it's so bad that you have to go to a
hospital
you got to pry about 20 20 percent
chance of dying yeah those people
evidently don't go to the hospital
yeah well I'm people don't even know
that in some ways they're saying that
and this happens in a lot of pandemics
they're like look sometimes and this
happened at the Spanish flu as well in
1918 they said if you have symptoms
sometimes it's better to not go to the
hospital yeah because it's like just
stay in your house because if you go out
and go in the hospital you'll just get
more of it and you'll infect other
chloral that maybe weren't infected so
maybe it's better not to go to the
hospital s you're like really really
really bad there's no cure for it
they're just gonna give you Town Hall or
Tamiflu or whatever and if you're real
old and starting
real sick I'm just gonna pump a bunch of
oxygen into your lungs yeah and try to
keep your now much like other flu
outbreaks it seems like most of the
fatalities for this from what I saw from
CDC this morning they said from between
75 to 80% of the fatalities when people
over 60 75 percent of them have had
other health issues usually my blood
pressure respiratory issues diabetes
diabetes that's like a big one too so
your motor or an ex-smoker your your
yeah so this seems to be in line like
unlike Spanish flu but we'll talk about
that a little bit unlike you know like
most other flu viruses this is attacking
people who are already older who are
already immunocompromised already have
other health problems it seems to be now
as of today like I said it's February
15th when we're recording this the CDC
is not recommending that the US like
freaked out or anything they said we
have 15 confirmed cases none of them
have died so they're like it is not
spreading here so just you know be aware
of what's going on but don't like flip
out you know what I mean yeah because
it's really not but it could spread
obviously but China is a little bit
different situation they're high
population density yeah
they don't shower as much as Westerners
do they don't wash the hands as much
soon like what are you talking about
their modern country go and go online
and go look at these damn wet markets
and go look at just like how it kind of
like your average poor people live there
well there's a reason why a lot of them
why a lot of these types of viruses
originated from wet markets because
these are you know they have like these
dead animals just kind of hang in there
and they're touching them and they're
touching other types of animals and yeah
you know [ __ ] like that so you there's a
channel called serpent za and it's from
a South African guy that married a
Chinese woman he lived in China for a
long time he doesn't live there anymore
but he made a whole bunch of videos on
SARS and why it spreads
Chinese will hock up loogies a lot and
they'll spit on a damn floor to spit on
the carpet in a restaurant and because
they think that's healthy you know and
they're clearing out their lungs that's
all macho this is that worthless
generation that was telling you about
that the Chinese trying to get rid of
this is this is their Buller proof that
old people are yes sir Boober sorry old
people I won't yeah evidently you know
evidently they're x-gen and millennia on
their version of like Zoomers they're
not like that you know they think that
shit's ridiculous it's [ __ ] gross
that's what and a Chinese boomer will go
into [ __ ] Starbucks and get a [ __ ]
cup and empty all the [ __ ] poor bunch
of creamer in there pour sugar in there
and put some ice in and sit there and
drink it because it's free belongs to
the people that kind of [ __ ] and they're
going to the bathroom and steal all
[ __ ] toilet paper because it's free
belong to the people
I've heard some poor us there like that
but I can't blame people yeah they're
like that but that's just like the norm
you know you know when you when you
mentioned that I actually found a
picture from the Spanish flu epidemic in
1918 and it was from some work site in
the u.s. somewhere I don't report said
it was in maybe was Boston and it was
like a big huge sign and it was saying
like Spanish flu and it's like you know
contagious and I've been a bottom it
really big it said don't spit yeah so I
guess like old people like spitting
that's the thing that was the thing that
a lot of people did back then you just
like spit in the fungus yeah I know
movers are way into that that was
they're so gross walk around their
shirts pulled up over and watch their
belly hanging out and I walk around like
that like a man does they're just like
all belly try to let the heat escape
who's gonna go around and like fart and
scratch around yeah yeah yeah serpents
ei he taught me all about um you know
Chinese
blow snot rocket any stylin Chinese
Chinese Boomer bling and just the way
they do things you know tricking men
walking around with a damn hand
eggs and yeah flip-flops barely sticking
it out I've seen that here though yeah
just a bag of money what it's like a
it's like a um watches it's super macho
yeah walking around was like a what do
they call those things that they used to
like strap around your weapon like a
fanny pack my fanny pack there yeah I
was I was thinking bum bag but that's
what they call them in the UK you can
tell her lived in the UK for a while I
couldn't remember the American name of
that yeah so now serpent za and and this
is kind of backed up by some witnesses
on the ground and people that are in the
hospitals in the Chinese oslo's they
don't have enough test kits yeah a test
kit is pretty expensive they're gonna
run out of [ __ ] and then the test kits
that they have are not very accurate
okay so if you go to the hospital
thinking that you have SARS they won't
even give you a test so they don't know
how many people are have it or not they
don't they just go out you're not that
bad go back home you know serpent
thought that he looked at all the
Chinese numbers he said just put a zero
at the end of every one of those figures
it's probably ten times well you always
have to assume that it's more because
wonder people might not go get medical
attention and he said that if if a
thousand people have died it's probably
more like ten thousand because some
people are dying a lot of people have
died in China yeah a lot yeah in China
right so I think well how many just how
he's died Chad I don't remember what
they it wasn't right no it was a lot
more than I actually um as far as I know
I can't really remember you certainly
check this separately saying that you
could probably put a zero at the end of
the death toll because his contacts in
China said that people were dying yeah
pretty much figured knew that that was
SAR that that was that that was corona
yeah
Arco vid 19 oh yeah yeah they know that
that's koban 19 but they can't prove it
so just say well it was a seasonal flu
it wasn't the kovin flu ya know what I
mean yeah cuz they do make a distinction
between the
but they're just made they're making
that distinction by pulling the
distinction out of the ass they're just
gonna looking at a dead guy and gone
well we can't prove it so he died of a
stomach ache they're doing a lot of that
[ __ ] to keep the death toll numbers down
although I have to tell you that when I
looked at the CDC site this morning and
I can't remember the number offhand but
it was the death toll was quite high so
they are reporting fairly high numbers
it's higher than that like yeah and it
probably is and like I said it's kind of
hard to keep track of especially in the
early days of a pandemic because one
some people might just get like a little
bit of sniffle and not go get medical
attention so they don't like keep track
of them
some people might stay home and they die
of [ __ ] they don't count that person and
it's like and they might be like you
know kind of keeping the number on the
down-low too but they're under reporting
it does seem like they have reported a
lot of deaths though and like I said you
know they seemed more open this time
than they did in the last flu epidemic
which is good but serpent's ei lived
there no you still don't know he's got
friends there he said put a zero on the
end of every number they tell ya and
that might be true about 10 times but
because might be true because the China
Chinese have a but they first of all
they're gonna want to save face all
right all the little people in charge
these little counties are gonna want to
under report so they don't get in
trouble so when a person dies they go
yeah he didn't die Ovid though he died
of a fever they're gonna say some [ __ ]
like that to make the death toll in each
one of these little areas little zones
because they have all these Party CCP
party managers in there you know they're
gonna be competing to who has the
smallest death number they don't the
death toll they don't want to show up in
the in in the data because a superior
above them and the CCP will punish them
they're either reporting I've actually
heard that like there's been like a lot
of some officials and like some doctors
and stuff like that that are like
breaking from the [ __ ] and are like
going out then report
and they're getting like kind of you
know one of them they put his ass in
prison and he died it'll [ __ ] code he
did yeah he got the disease and he was
30 so yeah they're they're gonna
downplay it yeah although like I said
from I was alarmed actually by the by
the number of deaths that they were
reporting and if it's more than that
I mean there have been some other cases
in other countries but as far as I know
like not anything to get like super
freaked out about but they have like
been reported they have reported an
actual very high number of fatalities in
China yeah and whatever they're
reporting is high and like I said it's
whatever Lee orders halt it's generally
older people it's generally people that
already had other house health issues
but you know it's probably higher than
that I would have seen serpents ei said
ten times it says that that's the
magnitude of that's the magnitude of
lying
the CCP does this is that would be
typical but like I said in a way even
though it seems draconian the fact that
they're like not letting people leave
cities and not letting people there
shutting down like whole cities pretty
much if that's good though they should
do that because that's a way to keep it
from [ __ ] spreading to everybody else
as soon as the Chinese figured out what
it was and like you said it took him a
couple weeks they jumped out of their
own [ __ ] have you ever seen a man
jump out of their own [ __ ] you gotta
jump off a high and off well they've
been through this before they had
[ __ ] SARS and that was like 10 years
ago their reaction was not one of just
well it's just a flu it they reacted
like it was a damn biological attack and
good thing it is a good day a good thing
but I think it's I I'm guarantee you
what serpent is saying that the death
toll is ten times of what they're
admitting to he's gonna be correct he's
gonna be correct well yeah I don't at
times that I don't doubt that it's
probably a lot more people in this day
but like I said you know if they have to
like shut down whole cities it sucks to
the people that live there they're
probably sick and everything like that
but it's like how else are you gonna
keep it from spreading to everybody else
I mean particularly nowadays you know
maybe back in the Middle Ages look at
the Middle Ages they
even like most people didn't even like
travel [ __ ] ten miles from where they
were born but look at nowadays you can
like be anywhere in the world in like a
few hours and diseases can spread that
quickly so you really have to be on that
[ __ ] I don't think they'll stop it
I think it's out of containment and it's
gonna be kind of like the Black Death to
where it'll burn and smolder in an area
and then seemingly go out and then a few
months later it comes back in another
area and then it burns and smoulders and
goes out and then it spreads it's gonna
be something like that it might gonna be
persistent well because I mean flus have
been kind of like that through history
yep
it's like you know yes there's the
seasonal flu like most people get some
kind of flu like every year but they're
kind of minor but every few years you
get this one that's kind of like really
really contagious really really virulent
and a lot of people get it and a lot of
people die from it and it seems like
like I said the last major one probably
2009 that was like a big you know kind
of pandemic particularly in Asia and so
it seems like this is another one that's
happening I don't like my gut feeling is
that it's gonna be out there working its
magic for about five years yeah we'll
see that's what I think it would be I
know it ones like I know I seem like I'm
not freaking out about it but it's kind
of like here's the thing hmm I have
anxiety issues as it is but I so I have
decided in my old age that I'm only
gonna worry about [ __ ] that I can
control and I can't control this it's
like if I get it and I die it's unlikely
I've said I and also I try to only worry
about things in proportion to the
likelihood that they will happen to me
you know and I feel like this is
probably it's very unlikely that I will
get it if I get it that sucks
I think I think eventually it's likely
that we will get it but I think it's
unlikely that it will kill you I don't
think it okay I think by the time it
gets here inside the United States and
and infects enough people for it to find
these
spread here to Florida it would have
mutated a little bit and it's probably
not gonna be that severe but that's what
I inter mean um you know they'll
probably get a little more mild natural
selection favors and more something mild
one because they don't want to kill the
hosts right
so it favors a more mild strain you
probably get it and it just feels like
any other flu that's what I mean and
generally I don't I mean I know I should
get a flu shot every year I don't think
I've ever got one because I don't ever
get the flu so I never bothered with it
I don't hardly ever get cold every now
and then I get one but not very often
like some people will get them every
year I don't get that career I don't get
much of anything sick I know that they
never have another thing is race is a
factor you have a virus that's really
working over to Chinese right now but
their genome is uniquely Chinese they're
very homogeneous you can identify a
Chinese person by their just their
genetic material very easily just
because it's working them over real well
doesn't mean it works over other races
of people to that same extent well how
it interacts with other people's genomes
you don't really know it could be worse
I could be better could be better but
you don't know you don't know people so
I mean it's you don't know so it's like
there's no point where you live kind of
like European and me an African type
ancestry have been through a lot of
[ __ ] plagues there it's been a sinner
that all the continents a lot of land
masses you know so maybe we've adapted
to [ __ ] you know I mean to fight off
new stuff well in having this better
yeah like having supermini it closed off
for a long time - yeah I mean being in a
way being isolated in the long term
that's bad in the short term it's
probably better because you don't get
like one particular one that comes about
in your life did you like but over the
yes right but yeah over the long term
you're gonna get Fox because it's like
yeah exactly like the Native Americans
it's like you know these Europeans show
up and like all of a sudden they have
all these [ __ ] diseases that you
don't have any immunity to because none
of them had ever come there yeah a lot
of that Indian genocide stuff that you
hear
I mean they did kill a lot yeah but it's
like our lot or the white man ever got
here it started when the [ __ ] Spanish
went to Mexico they [ __ ] brought that
damn so they still hang out with them
just not oh yeah this by the time the
Braves thought it came here even squat
to himself everybody wiped out yeah they
were all done it was put as they didn't
have any immunity to smallpox
yeah the smallpox got in there because
they've never ravaged North America oh
we gave them syphilis so fair yeah no
they gave us syphilis I thought no I
thought it went the other way around
actually I think it what the other
that's a good one is what you're getting
if not why you're like there's some
nasty [ __ ] man nasty if you seen
photographs of people before they people
don't really I mean do people die of it
nowadays people they used to though back
in the day people forgot what syphilis
did to you yeah that's terrible I saw a
photograph of a kid who was born by a
syphilitic mother looks just like Eddie
off the iron maiden there's photographs
of that kid it looks like a living
corpse no face exactly like Eddie made
or any form iron maybe if Eddie from
Iron Maiden on the album on there I made
goblin covers like off The Killers album
I think people forget like people forget
that that used to kill a lot of people
that virus it [ __ ] you up yeah it
doesn't really do it anymore like that's
what I mean and that's this is why I
kind of get annoyed by sorry if anyone's
an anti-vaxxer out there but I really
really get annoyed by anti-vaxxers
because it's like you guys obviously
never lived through people that had like
[ __ ] polio or that like died of
[ __ ] Shh I'm gonna speak up because
she's talking about sandy Baxter she's
talking about well there's other types
of anti-vaxxers yeah but there is also
companies have made bad vaccines right
but I would rather take my chance with a
vaccine then get [ __ ] polio or
measles or whooping cough
485 that is fine but people have died
from vaccines and there are bad vaccines
out there there are but like I said
here's the thing though you have to
weigh everything is risk in life you
know what I mean so I feel like the risk
of the vaccine is minuscule compared to
the risk of the disease you will get if
you do not get that I think in general
generalizing in general it depends on
the vaccine for instance like at the VA
they keep trying to do you want that do
you want the flu vaccine and I was like
no I can handle flu and here's the deal
it's it's good to get it when you're
older I'm on your side I'm thinking okay
maybe when I get 80 perfect or if you're
immunocompromised you need to get a kiss
the doctors never gave me a sufficient
answer with that flu vaccine okay I'm
looking at this like flu isn't deadly
you know it is for some people they told
me no flu isn't deadly okay well not for
you
yeah probably deadly and I said what
about the quality of that vaccine what
else is in there what how did it why did
the US why the why did the u.s.
government buy that vaccine and they
don't what they couldn't answer any of
that what maybe they just thought it was
a weird question
maybe there's maybe there's something in
there that would that was designed now
if I'm some company to kill me later so
the VA could save money now you're
thinking too much about I'm thinking
like a man because if I had to pay for
all these [ __ ] up in the
hospital I said what could I could what
could I give them to knock that mouth
five six years early that save me twenty
billion dollars I think you thinking too
much about well like I said I don't I
don't get a flu vaccine because I don't
usually get the flu but if I was over I
mean they recommend they really
recommend it for people that are amino
compromised or people that are over 65
because those are the people that will
usually die from the flu so some people
like to get them every year because they
just don't want to get the flu which is
fine I don't usually get the flu so I
don't bother with it but if I was like
older I would probably get one every
year just in case
well I don't want to give other people
[ __ ] diseases either because I'm
conscientious like that my rationale
behind it is what else is in that
vaccine is that is that a delivery
system for something else yeah I mean
that's the way I look at it well you
have a weird thing where you think
everyone's out to get you
yeah it's not an illusion yeah yeah okay
no one's out to get you ahead and think
that you go ahead and they was out to
get you okay I will see I understand
that I am such an insignificant person
in the world know that I'm just thinking
of the money if nobody gives a [ __ ]
about my ass come on like nobody wants
nobody will like engineer [ __ ] the VA
pays me to stay alive okay they do so
I'm thinking you know I they pay me so
I'm thinking that if they can increase
my mortality they would save money I
really don't think they're doing that
well I mean it's not just to me but
there's there's millions of me you know
talk about there's lots of guys not
really
so they're looking at it as they're
looking at it at a big chunk of change
sitting there I don't know who controls
the VA you know it might be this might
know this might be some [ __ ] 25 year
old dude with hot tubs and a bunch of
[ __ ] hot chicks and he's trying to
buy another damn mansion he doesn't give
a [ __ ] about my old ass you know Toby
he's got a harem to support you know
what I mean cuz that's what I'm thinking
yeah this is how I think yeah I don't
really that okay okay
I'm not being silly no cuz okay
don't worry too much about it you're not
worried about I didn't take it you're
worrying timid I didn't take I probably
wouldn't have felt like I said it's just
cuz I don't get the flu and I don't want
to once I get old I'll probably get one
just because I don't want to die from
that [ __ ] only I don't want to flaunt it
down I want to die on something epic no
you don't want the flu shot and I'm like
what you want me to take the flu shot
and they're like well as are the units
of what do you want me to take the flu
shot
no it's your choice and they were
probably like geez now why do you want
me to take
this flu shot you know Thank You Timmy
[ __ ] man they even give him like you can
go to [ __ ] CVS and get one for $10 if
you really like want to like I said well
I can to like I said I don't usually get
it so I don't worry about it but if I
was older or if I had some disease that
would like make me more susceptible to
what I would absolutely get it because
it's like I've gotten every vaccination
I was supposed to get and my entire life
I have almost never gotten sick I've
never gotten a cold or flu bad enough to
like have to stay in bed ever
yeah well I'm of the mindset to try to
take his little medicine as possible
yeah me too but ladies vaccines I mean I
would take a vaccine for some deadly
[ __ ] you know I mean especially if I
knew the baby without vaccines
particularly why you that it was a good
quality yeah and then it really worked
but [ __ ] you know my stepdad he died
from all the vaccines they gave him and
you know you can't prove that they paid
him you can't prove I think they did
because well the mean is in processing
into the into the Marine Corps as a
young man it was statistically his batch
of [ __ ] Marines died from Lou
Gehrig's and they think it was cuz when
they were coming in through him
processing they gave him like 20 [ __ ]
vaccines all about ten no it might have
been that or it might have been like a
million other things it was a common in
their service that God gave them yeah
but like I said it could have been a
million other things too like if you
can't prove this understanding was this
right but like I said yeah anecdotes are
not data okay so I'm just hanging this
smarty pants no I'm just saying it's
like what's the likelihood I'm thinking
like the likelihood of getting like a
regular vaccine like that you give to a
kid like an MMR you know what's the
chance of that going wrong or what's the
chance like getting like measles or
rubella or something like that which is
a disease that was pretty much wiped out
and not anymore oh because of all the
anti-vaxxers because they are from that
what would you did what would you think
what would you think about going through
a line alright and getting 20 vaccines
all at about five minutes
I do that yeah they were doing it but
that I think that had a long-term
[ __ ] I'm a statistical thinker that's
like if some bad if bad [ __ ] happens to
me individually that sucks for me but
it's like statistically I'm nobody I'm
like you know what I mean
so that doesn't matter to me as much do
you know what I'm saying yeah we got to
get back to pandemics they're probably
loving this [ __ ] I'm just saying it's
like to me it just seems like it's it's
a risk assessment he's a risk isn't a
third ten o'clock you're gonna get both
sides of the [ __ ] coin we don't agree
on everything all day yeah that's just
the way it is there's I see where she's
coming from yeah it's a risk assessment
I see where she's I worry about things
in proportion to how likely it is to
happen to me and another thing in one
another thing well another thing about
vaccines too is that you're not only
worrying about yourself it's you have to
worry about herd immunity as well the
less people get vaccinated the more
diseases that we thought were eradicated
at least in the United States are going
to creep their way back into the
population which means that I might get
that [ __ ] even though like I might get
polio because your stupid kid didn't get
[ __ ] vaccinated and that makes me
angry you're seeing vaccines in a world
of honest and good people that want to
help you alright
I'm seeing vaccines in a corrupt world
of people that want to get rid of it so
I kind of think that there's a
possibility that yes that vaccine works
it is a vaccine against that but inside
that vaccine they've also added some
other stuff that give you cancer on
purpose or something that would maybe
it's a vaccine an experimental vaccine
is inside that that might try to combat
like say HIV but that experimental
vaccine might be a bad word it will kill
you well here's the thing though I don't
they're gonna [ __ ] with you that's how
they go here's the thing though like
okay now I don't trust with them I know
that you know I don't either but here's
the thing I know that you like to say
that I think that like Oh humans are
good and [ __ ] like that now I don't
necessarily I think humans are
worst but I generally think that most
people will either be good or neutral
because it's too much trouble to be bad
they used to sell this [ __ ] back in the
[ __ ] days okay the thing is in the
early 1900's it was a damn radioactive
[ __ ] cure-all you would drink this
[ __ ] radium yeah and she was highly
radioactive a right yeah if they
believed that [ __ ] was good for you I
mean it was a photograph of dude his
entire bottom jaw is gone from drinking
I don't [ __ ] okay oh yeah I've seen I
don't trust I don't really but I'm here
here's the thing though you can't and I
can't remember offhand like what they
say well that's quackery and no no
that's not gonna say no that's not what
I was gonna say I was gonna say there's
a quote about this and I can't remember
like what what it was like word for word
but it's like you can't blame malice
when stupidity is the more likely option
and I just kind of feel like most of the
[ __ ] that like it was dude
like it was just because they didn't
know any better right well okay no one
was like maliciously God some of them
vaccines those [ __ ] might have
[ __ ] some [ __ ] up by accident right but
I thought yeah but I can't worry about
that because the thing is it's like I
have enough things to worry about okay
and it's like I can't control that and
like I said everything to me I don't
want I don't want you to just to
everything to me is a risk assessment
but I don't want you to give the show a
bad name like you're Payton all van
anti-vaxxers under the damn same
paintbrush there's a couple different
reasons why you should be skeptical I
don't think for religious reasons is one
of them I like these people that won't
get well if that's not really it I'm
sorry if you have a religious reagent
and that's the only reason they have
then you don't have a reason yeah I
don't think it's a reason because they
actually have people say well don't fix
my child's broken arm God will do it
yeah that kind of that's [ __ ] up
that's you know it's kind of dumb you
should have your kitchen I don't believe
in that kind of [ __ ] but the whole idea
of of that might be a bad quality
experimental vaccine and that's okay
yeah yeah I look at that kind of [ __ ]
or like yeah but here's the thing though
it's like
people that are worried about that they
will like eat food from the grocery
store they will like walk out and front
in traffic or whatever they will take
other risks every day and not think
about it in the same way that they think
about that which to me is dumb no I'm
just saying it's like it's all risk
assessment it's all risk assessment how
likely is it how likely is it that a
vaccine has something that somebody has
put in it to specifically kill you how
likely is it that you will get a disease
that will for sure kill you or make your
life really really unpleasant for a very
long time
you have to like weigh those two things
like you don't take that vaccine you
never get sick well that's a possibility
as well so that's one but I'm yes so
that's another thing that you have to
take into consideration wanting
something but I'm just saying that the
things that they vaccinate you for you
know like that you know they get the
kids like MMR vaccines and stuff like
that you know that seems to me the the
risk of that vaccine is of something
being wrong with that vaccine is so
[ __ ] low in comparison to how
unpleasant the disease is well I've
never turned down every vaccine I've
taken a lot of them yeah so am i it's
just that when they asked you about that
flu when I turned that one down because
that's not a deadly disease not more
like I said not for you it's for some
for some people like I said I it's an
unnecessary risk I'm not saying like if
people want to do the flu vaccine every
year like some people do and that's fine
it's like I don't because I don't get
the flu and it doesn't really bother me
that much but if I was older or if I had
an immuno compromised or if I was
immunocompromised then yes I would
indeed took all kinds of vaccines going
through the army yeah I've had all my
[ __ ] vaccine I don't think I had
never had any I'm not into into all this
I'm gonna get some extra vaccines I'm
not into that but like I said they were
just giving you they didn't make you
take it they just asked you if you
wanted it yeah and I was like nah damn
I'm finna try to guilt-trip me like that
like they mean they were gonna get a
commission off of it and I started to
get suspicious I'm alright
because well here's the thing like I I
feel like you have this thing you kind
of feel like everyone is doing stuff
at you you know what I mean yeah that
that's how it is you know I mean and
it's like most of the most people in the
world like nobody in the world pretty
much like most 99.99% of the people
don't give a [ __ ] about you that I give
a [ __ ] about me
they're not thinking about they're
thinking about their own damn self and
it's like so which in a way that's very
freeing because so I don't care about it
no one is like maliciously trying to do
anything to me do you know I mean and
and and if you think that that's kind of
like that's a little bit of a red flag
I'm doing it at me yeah I mean it's just
you thought they were trying to kill you
with the vaccine though I'm not them
maybe somebody up and higher echelon
it's above reality maybe that's some
kind of a [ __ ] you know eugenics
program you know I mean I didn't think
it was like them you know but the people
who made the vaccine yeah I don't know
who this is but they didn't know who was
gonna take it they just they just make
flu vaccine comes off the [ __ ]
factory I imagine wouldn't care just be
like yeah I ain't gonna take it kill all
them people you know well like I said
make all cops flu vaccine I'll make an
exception for that because I don't take
it personally [ __ ]
I don't imagine it killing you like on
the spot it'd be like something that way
well I would hope not that'd be a little
15 years now you come down with like
some [ __ ] dick cancer or something
like that yeah it's me something like
that right but the thing about it is
like what if you would have got dead
cancer anyway what if you would have
gotten dick cancer anyway there's no way
of knowing that I just would have blamed
in fact sees ahead that's what I mean
and see see that's another problem
another problem is that every look every
psychology I've taken every psychology
class I take it that's what I'm saying
every psychology class I've taken every
critical thinking class I've taken a
pound you into your head correlation is
not causation this is the show meaning
just because something happened after
that
that doesn't mean I'm that caused I niak
hear your [ __ ] Brainiac you're like
post hoc ergo we gotta get on we got to
get back to we got to give it stop
trying to reason with me I'm not
reasonable
we're gonna have to talk about the black
death but probably we should we should
take a break so I can get another drink
and then well do we ever get down the
bottom I think we pretty much wrapped up
though yeah it's like everybody is
dangerous focused it is but [ __ ] calm
down seriously I mean we've only had a
few cases have you been to China then
you probably should worry about it it's
homework China over it just stay home
it's like try not to in fact wear a mask
try not to infect other people it's
gonna be a while before it gets here
and chances are but stars I remember
when stars happen in 2009 and I remember
everybody in the news like flipping out
about that I'm like immune to everybody
look like flipping out on the news
because they do it all the time yeah so
I'm so in a way that's kind of bad
because they cry wolf so much that it's
like it's something really bad happen
I'd be like man whatever cuz it's like
they're always like crying about
whatever but it's alright by the time he
gets to the u.s. population I think
it'll be kind of watered down that's
what I mean so I'm just kind of drying
if you have a little bit more how likely
is it that it's gonna that I'm gonna get
it and even if I get it am I gonna die
from it that is very very unlikely so
I'm not worrying about it this [ __ ] can
make its way into Africa Africa wouldn't
even notice it I don't think they got so
many other they have so many other
problems because having deadly diseases
they have gone over there right now well
that's well and they've got dave's
they're still like having AIDS yeah
pandemic and [ __ ] like that
that's still going on they wouldn't even
notice this probably not there's like oh
boy another thing but I think China is
the perfect breeding ground for this one
and it's it's gonna get them way worse
than it gets the United States and the
Europe I believe yeah it probably will
and like I said they seem to have done
an okay job of containing it so far so I
mean there have just been very very
isolated cases in other places so we'll
see how it goes maybe dry of them
terrorists though cuz they're gonna get
samples of this right but it's like what
is that not as good as they both
although Ebola you know doesn't spread
that quickly it's more deadly it's a
different type of yeah it patted this
well the flu viruses are always more
deadly because they can pass just
through the air
you can just sneeze on somebody and this
would make a better bio weapon I think
than Ebola Ebola is blood-borne is it
not or it's or it's much harder to just
harder it doesn't transmit it to
transmit but this one transmits easily
but it's just not that deadly if you
keep giving it to a country over and
over again you could cause a lot of
havoc especially economic havoc but
eventually I think that population and
Biblical resistance to it well and I
think that's what happened when we talk
about Spanish flu that's I think that
might have been what happened and why
Spanish flu like killed
disproportionately younger people were
usually it would killed our people and I
think that might have been a factor
because of another flu pandemic that had
happened earlier that had like given
immunity to like older people but yeah
so um let's take a break I want to come
back and we'll talk about black death
and we'll talk about Spanish flu and
stuff because we won't wait we when I'm
waiting for about coronavirus that I
meant to that was just supposed to be
like a little like bit at that it's
common I mean technically we're still
talking about pandemics yeah that's what
I said the show was about so you know
drink so quit your bitching yeah yeah
yeah we got to go find baby cookies
outside run around on the bush alright
so we're gonna take a break we will be
back in just a few minutes oh my
goodness where we going where we going
you're subjective well what you dealing
look a little pale what's the matter
what's the matter poking you don't love
mommy and daddy the more you don't love
us no more
money okay where are you going where are
we going where are we going what are you
doing hope you doing oh you're going to
the tree playing I see yeah that's right
you can add some Creek you're still
family you love true crime
I love true crime and I've spent the
last three years compiling a series of
the most intriguing unsolved murders of
the 20th century it's called the
faceless villain and volume three is
available now featuring such fascinating
cases as the Caddy murders the carry
babies case the Frog Boys the al-qasr
murders and the inokashira park
dismemberment incident the faithless
villain volume three is an involving
exploration of unsolved slang spanning
the years from 1980 to 1999 pick up your
copy and print or eBook formats on
Amazon or download the audiobook version
from audible.com and get ready for a
chilling journey through modern crime
history
all right we're back back talk about
pandemics and homeopathic medicine we
were talking about colloidal silver
because I take that [ __ ] she's making a
fun like your turn blue thank you I
don't want to hang out with a smurf come
on now
I should done work Chinese medicine
works without millions of Chinese people
yeah there's something called the
placebo effect it's fine that's what it
is than fine
so I so I'm at some actively working
against you by telling you that [ __ ]
doesn't work it will turn you blue I
like serious I don't take that much of
it though okay we'll see Ward's off evil
all right [ __ ] it Silverman so you won't
get even by any werewolves I think but
like I said happy Oh like that's like
it's like it's not quite the same cuz
I'm a man in motion some cuz there is
actually some [ __ ] in it albeit stuff
that your body doesn't actually need but
homeopathic medicine that's a whole
other thing you might as well just
[ __ ] drink water with that Jeff any
of you that's all that is yeah if any
people have any kind of faith in any
kind of you might as well just to click
off now cuz so if I can destroy your
faith and [ __ ] I don't believe it
doesn't work it's like psychological
warfare my [ __ ] that my [ __ ] my
[ __ ] bond ya know my willpower is suck
is strong enough where I can [ __ ]
convinced myself of anything and it
works yeah ok yeah pretty much
that's good I'm like spa career I'm just
like I'm kind of like I guess I'm I
guess that means I'm [ __ ] Kirk well I
think we've gotta go into that before
that's that's why if anybody's asking
cuz I think some people were like they
were very happy on the Valentine show
that we kind of went into a like our
origin story a little bit but it's like
I think that's kind of why we work out
very well because that's pretty much
exactly the dynamic you watch Star Trek
the original series your Kirk and that's
it exactly it's like it's that's it
that's very funny yeah but yeah I think
that's very
yep it is I ain't joking yeah that's not
a joke at all alright so let's talk
about the Black Death you want to yeah
all right so the Black Death which most
people know like I said it wasn't just a
one-time event it was it happened like
over successive decades but the worst
part of it happened between 1347 and
1352 estimated to have killed between
I've heard between thirty million and
fifty million people which you know
considering this was back in the [ __ ]
1300 before they knew had a cow town of
people man it was like half the popular
breathily like half the population so
you can remember so you can like so you
can think of how it must have been for
people of that time period and suddenly
half the people it was a [ __ ] drive
people crazy for generations the [ __ ]
you can't blame them right lurid [ __ ]
paintings of [ __ ] there's some great
fancy bodies and dead bodies like
Hieronymus Bosch yeah weird pilgrimages
and [ __ ] weird Crusades
you know like [ __ ] the flagellants
yeah people just walking around moaning
and wailing and just weird [ __ ] I did
was like I understand they thought they
thought it was God's judgement yeah they
didn't um obviously this was the
medieval period so they did not
understand the germ theory of disease if
you told my germ theory they'd [ __ ]
kill you yeah they'd probably think yeah
burn at the stake so that yeah that's
wrong what they were thinking so you can
imagine like how scary it was I think
some people knew them they won't know I
think they did too because the damn
plague doctors those masks with all the
damn flowers and [ __ ] because they
thought smells is Erasmus with miasma
miasma I thought my asthma's we're doing
it well by what what is that what is the
vehicle of the miasma that's kind of
like
proto concept of something going in you
something small going in you and making
you sick that is kind of yeah it's I was
thinking that when I was watching
because I watched a couple documentaries
on this there's one that actually has
Leonard Nimoy um narrating it which was
very nice and there was another one that
was like somebody else but it's like
that was one thing that I thought of
it's like it sounds dumb that they
thought that stinky air was causing the
plague but that's the same as the air
but they weren't that far right if you
think about and you that damn mask with
the big beak filler like the Birdman the
big doctor mask that's an effective gas
mask for plague yeah because when you're
dealing with bio even though the virus
is [ __ ] tiny tiny tiny it doesn't get
into you on its own it gets into you in
little droplets of water so if you have
something in between you and the outside
world that can catch those droplets of
water then that's up there that's a
[ __ ] cross that's the that's as good
as a damn mask a surgical mask make it
better so that that plague doctors
outfit
that's a [ __ ] that's a [ __ ]
biosuit that worked yeah and that's why
they lived or ahead or at least it must
have given some kind of protection it
didn't work for the reasons that they
thought it was working but it was
working yeah well because anything that
covered up your face right when I'm not
breathing it can't spit particles and
[ __ ] blood particles that were in the
air or so it worked now what would they
get infected anyway when they took the
mask off and [ __ ] cross-contaminated
yes yeah but that was probably it would
be it would increase your chances of
[ __ ] survival I had that damn flies
no no no you were doing that stuff well
and especially because these were
doctors so they had to like go to the
bedsides and the role that already had
it so in a way it was good thinking
yeah I mean like I said in their
rudimentary way they did understand that
a person that had it now they also did
think that it said if a person that had
the plague looked at you then that would
give you the plague also so
so some of the plague doctor masks had
like these like red crystal things like
over there over the eyehole agency so
they couldn't really see it make icon
that was like another yes so that was
like which like I said that's dumb but
it's like they didn't know that at the
time but they were on the right track
well there's right that's good still
good thinking it is it is still good
thinking because what you had in the
Roman era the idea of the [ __ ] evil
eye okay okay so that comes into factor
but it's just the whole idea of trying
to separate yourself from the sick yeah
you're not even seeing them yeah you can
put my [ __ ] black my crystal on I
can't see it I'm fine
now are you yeah I'm fine so it the
thinking is actually pretty sound I mean
yeah that's another civilization it
might be even wackier like a hang a
[ __ ] damn prom frond over my head and
I'm fine I mean there might be some
island civilizations that might think
that or like in Brazil you know I'm in
where the women you know tie in little
Tonga's around their [ __ ] waist which
is a damn little dental floss which to
prevent rape yeah how'd that work out
they didn't get raped they didn't have a
[ __ ] on because they had that on so you
couldn't rape them well you know I have
this particular shade of red lipstick on
and that prevents me from getting eaten
by Tigers yeah exactly my proof is I had
that on us far beneath magical thinking
but I understand it yeah and and like I
said John believed it
oh well she's got that on can't read it
that's what I mean if it becomes a
widespread enough belief it becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy right yeah and
like I said the plague doctor suits like
you said you know a lot of the [ __ ] that
they did was dumb and it's like they
were doing it for like dumb reasons or
incorrect reasons let's say that but in
practice it did kind of work out we're
calling it dumb it was theoretical yeah
okay
they didn't know who they were
experiment
they didn't know what's causing it still
worked it like I said they either
thought that God was punishing them or
that stinky air was causing it it was a
gas mask and having lenses on the gas
mask would [ __ ] prevent those
particles from going into your eye and
spreading it yeah okay so that said they
were come maybe yeah thinking was right
yeah because you see a mask isn't enough
you have to have as your eyeballs are
kind of right you're not balls are also
weigh in so the lenses the thinking was
correct that you should isolate yourself
as much as possible from the diseased
yeah and having a lens is better than
not having a lens yeah the idea of well
we're gonna prevent him from looking at
me so therefore I won't be kid that's
just part of the of the quarantine yeah
they're making a quarantine yeah you're
trying you're overcompensating I can't
see me you can't see me I can't see him
ain't no way I'm gonna get sick sorry I
totally annoyed yeah and like they did
seem to understand on some level that
contact with somebody that had had the
illness even though they didn't know
what was causing it they didn't know
about germs they didn't know about
things there's no problem yeah but they
instinctively knew hey let's not because
even people that were sick like their
own family members and this is [ __ ] up
but like their own family members
no [ __ ] coronavirus sure but yes even
their own family members would like be
like yeah I'm out yeah because you know
and they're like hey please take care of
me I'm sick and everything they're like
ya know yeah this is probably one of the
worst diseases in [ __ ] recorded
history it is there was some stuff
happening in the in the Roman Empire the
late Roman Empire that was bad too that
we don't really understand it might had
something dude there was the Justinian
plague there's like the Antonin no need
plague I think some people figured what
that happened I think that was typhus
actually yeah there's a lot of a head do
with the impure water and cross
contamination yeah yeah
improper damn sewage and know what
sewage mixing with drinking water is
seriously people did not understand and
I will recommend this book right here
which is called the ghost map this is
about a really bad cholera epidemic that
happened in the UK in the 1800s and that
was how they figured out that cholera
was caused by water that had been
polluted with human sewage because they
didn't know that beforehand right so
this book is about like the one doctor
that figured that out and nobody wanted
to listen to him because they thought he
was high and came out of you I can't go
back Andy how could anything be bad
about human [ __ ] why can't we just have
like piles of [ __ ] outside the [ __ ]
hell we have a [ __ ] pot in our house
with a lid on right yeah it's like you
just have the poop as far away from you
as possible it's like that it smells bad
for a reason but yes oh yes oh the Black
Death like I said the worst um
you know the worst outbreak of it even
though there were several subsequent
outbreaks was from 1347 to 1352 I have
seen estimates from between 30 million
people to 50 or 60 million like I said
it usually says it killed you know about
half the population of Europe at the
time now what they didn't know then but
that what we know now is that the
disease was actually carried by fleas
which were on rats particularly black
rats and the disease had actually come
from Central Asia the reason that it
didn't spread there was because one it
wasn't as unsanitary as here I guess and
the the people were more nomadic so they
were like more spread out so they didn't
really have a chance to like kind of all
gather in these like filthy cities where
they were all living on top of each
other and like having their sewage in
the streets and have no right and stuff
like that so it didn't really spread so
they're not right so they're not
entirely sure where I mean maybe the
you know the bacteria for this has
always existed in fleas you know or
whatever but it just seems like it
couldn't get a foothold in Asia where it
originated they think just because the
you know the the human conditions were
not correct you know what I mean but
what ended up happening was that even
though the disease originated in Central
Asia it was actually taken but like the
Mongol warriors and traders and stuff
like that who were going in and out of
Europe actually probably ended up taking
it there because what ended up happening
was that the fleas were on the rats if
the rats died of the plague then the
fleas would jump on to the humans yeah
and the rats were living underneath the
floorboards underneath your little
[ __ ] peasant house yeah and in the
winter they would be up in there and
we're talking about lots of rats we're
not talking about a modern idea of yeah
there's a rat no there's a couple right
couple hundred rats living underneath
your house and a big old [ __ ] fast
you know rat fest they actually had some
[ __ ] yeah they've actually had some [ __ ]
they've showed it I saw a picture of
covers called they thought it had
something do the wet witchcraft every
now and then they would see a huge ball
of rats jumping down the damn road all
their [ __ ] tails tied together you
seen that thing mm-hmm what's that thing
called do you remember no they were
giving it damn Germanic names and like
trying to figure out what the hell is
because the rats were cold and they were
just sleeping so close to each other
under the house and there were no tails
it could cause a not read have like 30
rats tied together by the tail they're
like did it by themselves and they come
up underneath the house and a big old
ball try to run in every direction at
once and it would freak the [ __ ]
villagers out they would thought that
Dam dam which was approaching you know
[Laughter]
so underneath some people in the Middle
Ages they got everything is witchcraft
ergo [ __ ] it with that so in or in old
Europe back in the action Hongki
motherland when it got cold okay you
might have [ __ ] hot eyes of rats
living underneath your house yeah
because you had a fire going in there so
you don't I mean they're like old man
get in here yeah it's warm right well
when they started dying to plague the
rat that the [ __ ] fleas would jump on
the other rats yeah baby hos rises up on
those other rats and you'd have [ __ ]
millions of generations that damn fleas
jumping on to the rats as they die until
there's no more rats and then they just
come up out underneath your house
thousands and thousands of [ __ ] fleas
jumping on the he was jumping on the
human because you because we had a right
to carry and plague
yeah your ass was [ __ ] gone they just
didn't have any kind of medical
understanding well in the problem -
particularly in medieval Europe was that
particularly in you know let's say lower
income yeah you would have like entire
family's living in one room it's not
like nowadays where everybody has their
own room and it's not one room yeah
everybody like there would be like 20
people instead of having a different
room for your kids and you you just all
step in the same bed let you suddenly
put a board in between you to shield the
kids from the sex board that's some
[ __ ] up my kids to be like peeking it
like what the hell's going on all there
probably they were like yeah but I guess
it was like normal to them yeah but you
know it was the kind of situation it's
in a way China's still like that there's
no expectation of privacy I cannot you
might have three generations of a family
living this in an apartment you know me
and Grandma is always in your [ __ ] wants
to know where you're going then they
want to look at your damn laptop and
they want to see what's going on
understand where you're going yeah
everything's authoritarian their ass
serpent za that's a [ __ ] that's a
great Channel and Lao I so may touches
my laptop I'm girl there's anything bad
on there so they were dating in China
the girl grab your phone and go through
your friend list and look at all your
conversation you go what are you doing
you're talking to they don't have any
kind of it that's just the cultural it's
just a culture they don't have any
[ __ ] concept it's like we did that
here something like [ __ ] knock they
got from a totalitarian regime where
everything is [ __ ] surveillance see
what I mean so it's just normal to them
everybody gotta know everybody's in
somebody else's [ __ ] yeah it's not it's
not American at all you can watch it I'm
gonna bust you up don't get my [ __ ] well
yeah my guess that's a smile well
honestly I don't ever it really never
occurs to me to like look into their
people [ __ ] anyway one because I don't
really give that much of a [ __ ] about
other people but I'm here right yeah
yeah it's like I don't really care but
it's weird because even some other like
Americans like I've heard of like other
people I know and they're like oh they
go over to somebody's house that they're
like dating or whatever and they like go
through their medicine counter it's like
that would seriously that would never
occur to me one I don't care what's in
their medicine kit why would I care
what's in their medicine cabinet I want
to see if you're sick why would I care
about that it's like if you don't have
any [ __ ] bodies in the basement I got
some people that were raised raised bad
I would never go through somebody else's
stuff in their house that would never
occur to me it just really wouldn't that
programmer they had that guy where every
time you go to a girl's house you'd have
to go into a shower pull the [ __ ]
drain out and pull the hair out here on
Obama dream yeah I know what the hair
ball look like in the bottom of the
drain that's some weird [ __ ]
okay well that guy is clearly disturbed
but it's an exam it's just an
exaggeration disaster inform what we're
talking about yeah but I see I've never
it has never occurred to me when I go to
somebody's house like a friend's house
that I've never been to before it would
never occur to me to go through their
stuff it's just it wouldn't occur to me
yeah and if somebody like would come
over to my house and go through my stuff
I'd be like what the [ __ ] are you doing
get your ass busted yeah I'm just gonna
catch ya Jenny put the [ __ ] strap-on
on come and pega by the [ __ ] oh I will
[Laughter]
he's not into like I mean but I'm not
that mean I'm kind of mean though it was
funny though just [ __ ] come over that
you tell that [ __ ] tequila's kick of
my ass right
but yeah I'm just trying to imagine the
plague see well like I said back in
those days it's like a freaked out it's
terrible nowadays yeah
like cuz no one wants to get like a
horrible illness and die obviously or
watch their loved ones get a horrible
illness and die but it has to be several
orders of magnitude worse you get that
and you don't know what it is well
actually they thought they knew what it
was they thought it was [ __ ]
supernatural they thought well the wrath
of God like they thought it so that was
[ __ ] yeah or stinky air yes my stinky
air is something but I it was my
understanding that most of them thought
it was punishment they did and there and
as a result of the plague spreading
throughout Europe there were like all
these like crazy like religious like
offshoot groups like the flagellants and
stuff like that I should tell them about
what the symptoms were well okay well
let me kind of go back to work we're
going off in all different directions
this is like probably the drunkest show
we've done in a while it's not that
wrong I will too probably because I
still have one mole in segment two but
you know what I mean so anyways so like
I said even though the plague had been
present but as far as they know like in
China for a while but it hadn't really
got a foothold in the human population
because you know the the way the human
population lived was not conducive to it
spreading to any large extent however
when it got taken into Europe by the
Mongol warriors and traders it ended up
coming into Europe via Italy they think
came in by a ships or rather rats on
ships that were coming into the Genoese
trading ships that were coming from the
Black Sea now two-thirds of people that
got this disease died from it
so it's a very very high mortality rate
estimated between 30 and 50 percent of
the population died from the black death
now so many people died that as we
mentioned earlier it ended up having
like huge like far-reaching consequences
to medieval society as a whole one of
the main things being like the end of
serfdom this was probably the main
factor that caused that I mean I'm sure
there were probably other factors
because there always are but this seemed
like the main factor that kind of you
know because right into that what year
are we talking about this is thirteen
like mid 1300 right
and of serfdom yeah that's it it
definitely did like but because like I
said it wiped out so many people that
there was such a labor shortage that
actually plays into the beginning of
African slavery because yeah right
because what is happening is that they
couldn't Rhian slave white people but
you had black slaves appearing on the
market and the church okayed it said
that well because they're heathens all
right then it's okay and they're captive
you can go ahead and buy them because we
can introduce them to Christianity and
that's what the that's what at least one
of the Pope's said so that oh I'm sure
it was so so that okay that was their
whole stick right and because the
population wasn't high enough there
wasn't an excess of white people at the
time to worry because you have to have
an excess before you can start enslaving
people it's weird but well people have
to be has always been a supply and
demand situation it is that's the
messed-up way of thinking of it as well
is it kind of works out that way right
so the fact that serfdom ended around
this time period was pretty much like I
said I'm sure there was other factors
that was too high it had to do a lot
with like the plague because so many
people had died and so many people that
were left were just like you know [ __ ]
this I don't need to put up with this
crap anymore you know pay me or I'm
leaving
right so a lot of that did kind of
contribute like I said it was a big
contributor to the Renaissance is well I
had the plague never happened there
never would have been African slavery
there have been no need that might be
there'd been a point that you could
argue sure there have been no demand
yeah why by black people when you had
free white people right that came with
any piece of land that you bought yeah
they weren't worth anything yeah yeah I
mean that was the thing like every
pretty much up until the Black Death
happened right that was kind of like the
whole medieval set up was like you kind
of had your castle with your [ __ ] you
know your ruler or whatever and they
like had all of these residents that
lived on the [ __ ] we got black fans
and subscribers [ __ ] you know you
there's what a particulars think of that
my mind if you want to [ __ ] blame
slavery or one thing that we figured it
out all right well like way it's always
more than one thing it's many fun that
was a main factor it was a huge deal
because you have to think how many
people this killed right that made a
huge hit sure huge dent the population
culturally and you couldn't read enslave
white people after that yeah they went
had there was a there was a shortage of
Labor and black slaves were available on
an international slave trading market
yeah and the Pope said it was okay
because we that was a way to spread
Christianity and then soon after that
discovery of the new world the
colonization of the new world so that
increased it which was another pandemic
that was a whole other thing that was
inevitable that's just [ __ ] migration
it would have happened no matter what
yeah it's that's the thing it's like
it's you couldn't prevent any of this no
it's gonna happen at some point yet
people try to politicize this and
racialize it would have happened no
matter what race was anywhere the North
America Central and South America the
population density was low the rest of
the world the population density was
relatively higher the also in Europe the
agricultural technology allowed a
certain amount of yield per acre egde it
was very high comparison to say North
America so when those North when those
European Kings saw North America and
realized how big it was all they could
think of was how much food you could
grow on it and that was it they were
gonna colonize it just there would've
been no stopping it
well and number one rule of history if
you're poor you're gonna get [ __ ] in
the ass no matter what color you are
yeah
so you know although I argue that okay
all right let's go I'm gonna argue that
the Europeans in a way were poorer than
the Indians because the American Indians
at that time first there was a different
kind of civilization they had everything
they needed those [ __ ] were
badasses they were they spent most of
the time whip and white people's asses
they did it wasn't until much really and
like we said you know diseases white
diseases so they were decimated right I
mean these guys were on the level of
samurai and they were [ __ ] in some
cases [ __ ] highly developed cultures
with written histories and [ __ ] their
own agricultural systems going on and
everything you know you're not talking
about [ __ ] they were players to what
got them was the Telegraph and and the
[ __ ] railroad once that happened the
age of the Great Plains Indian Roman the
following the Buffalo that just that was
done a lot of ways I think that at the
time of the European conquest you could
argue that the Native Americans were
living much better lives oh yeah a lot
of the years that's what I meant I meant
that they were not poor they were richer
because they had a much better quality
yeah they're my life was better and that
you had so many white people defecting
to Indian tribes and I can totally
understand a huge majority of them which
is something they don't want to tell you
white women white women loved Indians
they just did they would capture some
Indian tribes a separate Union because
what it is is that a white woman could
have a higher status in an Indian tribe
hired that she could have in a white
town especially if maybe she had kind of
a spotty past she could start a new life
and that was a very free living clean
living in the field and you know I mean
the army reported it many times that
they would [ __ ] stop Indians and take
the white women from them because some
of them they were captives the army
would the army be like hey stop it
yeah
morning in the white women were gone we
wanted to go because they went back yeah
I can't blame them I you know having
studied like how Native Americans
situated you know civilizations were
structured and how European
civilizations were structured at the
time for women particularly I think I
probably would have like yeah acted as
well I would say what beyond any shadow
of a doubt I say this as a [ __ ] as a
[ __ ] patriotic American that's sir
the Indians were more American than the
lifestyle of an Indian the mentality
Venini was in a way a lot more American
than the white colonists from Europe
they were they were British but they
weren't really American like for
instance you would the Seminole Indians
here in Florida they were mostly Irish
or half Irish and you'd had black
Seminole Indians yeah it was kind of
like I was a mixed it was kind of like a
mixed bag tribe yeah and and the
cultural values that they had we could
recognize yes there were a lot they were
variation of their time in right in
contrast to the Europeans they seemed
that later yeah more their values have
more lineup with our values today then
yeah then European values from back then
European mentality really couldn't make
it for the long haul that you know in
the new world it wouldn't work out not
flexible enough to class oriented too
[ __ ] hard to orderly too much in too
much dependency on [ __ ] laws or you
know complicated laws Indians weren't
like that yes it was an honored basis we
don't like that [ __ ] Harriet you don't
even to this day the common people
unites is more of an honor based society
than a legalistic society we have laws
but when you understand Americans it's
actually more of an honor based society
yeah well and like I said Americans are
very when and you know like I said it's
a generalization but Americans in
general are very anti hierarchical
authoritarian right not all of them
obviously some of them kind of more
freewheeling more flexible and
Brazilians even
so having grown up in Brazil even war so
they're anarchists but in a good way
I like Brasilia except for their driving
we're driving to [ __ ] out in it which
hot sofa has Moses much horrifies me
yeah and and people the way people drive
in Orlando horrifies me but I've read
about people drop result result that's
what I mean that would horrify me well
then maybe that's why you're driving
scarcely I don't drive like a procedure
that's true yeah that's very scary yeah
well they drive like like they don't
care if they die or not they go look at
the toxoplasmosis rates in [ __ ]
Brazil although like I said race cars
the thing about Orlando is that so many
people here
well are not from Florida like you know
what I mean I am but like a lot of
people aren't and so your highways here
in Orlando we're kind of everyone lives
it's kind of like this big free-for-all
of people just from everywhere from all
over the United States all over the
world everywhere so they're all bringing
their own unique driving experiences to
the Orlando area and it shows it's like
every time we have to go on i-4 I just
get I I just trying to when he's driving
I just kind of close my eyes and
Williams are all rowing hits me
Brazilians are all racecar drivers it's
like they don't they want to be in front
of the traffic jam yeah I understand it
but they're trying to outrun [ __ ] that
you can't outrun that you can't outrun
yeah yeah this is this does not make any
sense to me well these people people do
it here too because I'm like worried
you're busy and I think is it maybe well
you've heard me say some [ __ ] yeah that
[ __ ] South America because I'm
like worried it's like there's there's
there's like a backup there's like a
traffic jam because it's i-4 there's a
traffic jam like all the time so it's
like they're going but they're like
racing toward I'm like where do you
think you're going exactly should
presume would do traffic jam like no
one's moving all right I love it
even though it's like 10 miles down the
[ __ ] Road but yeah whatever alright so
like I said we were talking about Black
Death so alright so bubonic plague even
though like I said there are there are
more than one type of plague but bubonic
plague was the most common one during
this time period you know this was the
most common during the 14th century
outbreak and this is the reason it's
called bubonic plague is because it
causes these big huge growths like on
your lymph nodes usually like in your
armpits and your groin areas big like
[ __ ] and some of the [ __ ] is like
I've seen as big as an egg or as big as
an apple and the Bubo Bubo is that's
what they were called boils yeah that's
what they were yes so there's like these
big [ __ ] growths like all and that
was kind of like the first onset like
that's how you knew that you had the
[ __ ] which must been horrifying must be
your glands it is yeah and these would
often turn black which i think is what
got it didn't get called the Black Death
until later on but I wonder this kind of
white extracted somebody's glads if it
would cause them to live
I bet you the [ __ ] reaction of those
glands producing all kinds of [ __ ]
weird I don't know something I wear to
anybody's a [ __ ] that's probably what's
killed them me yeah I'm not a lot of
times you killed by your own immune
system I know is I thought well I think
that's what happened in this in the
Spanish flu thing was that you know what
do they call a cytokine storm or
whatever they call it where it's kind of
like your immune system like
overreacting like holy [ __ ] Chu all the
white blood cells yeah and when that
ends up killing yeah and sometimes like
what it's overreacting to isn't isn't
really in itself a big threat that if
you yeah didn't have an immune system
the [ __ ] would just float around in your
blood for a while and then you just piss
it all out wouldn't matter
I brought I'd rather have it at me it
would made me it would make me wonder
you know if I was a monk back in those
days with a sharp blade you know what I
mean I like well I'm gonna do an
experiment this guy's gonna die let's
cut all these things off of him I'm sure
they probably thought of that yeah you
think so I mean you would think that was
the first thing that you would think of
it's like well this is where the disease
is so let's cut that off and leave
yeah let's see what happens so I'm
assuming nothing to work because I've
never seen anybody say anything
well mostly the church didn't want you
cutting into the human body yeah that
thing about it that's why they didn't
really like know what the inside of the
body looked like yeah the Romans did
though they were cutting live cows apart
and [ __ ] didn't why they were alive
and cut you know and evidently people
didn't like it but they couldn't really
object to because it wasn't human
yeah I remember reading that there was a
Roman physician that would vivisect
living cows that were tied down so they
could see you know and people were
amazed but they were also kind of like
didn't like the fact that the cow
sitting there if I could screaming well
yeah I don't like that either so it's
like I'm all for scientific advancement
and stuff but come on
like don't make a cow suffer yeah well
they say ancient Romans thought the same
way
yeah but they were very interested they
were trying to figure out what the hell
made things work yeah look that's good
right that's good and they weren't
allowed to eat the Romans themselves
weren't allowed really to do a lot with
dead bodies there was for religious
purposes they were supposed to treat
well yeah that went on until the
Renaissance yeah because I mean I feel
like you know people that you know
scientists that wanted to experience
experiment on human bodies you don't
slide you had to do yeah or you can't
like go steal bodies or gonna like go
dig him off from a lot by I'm try yeah
yeah did you [ __ ] like that yeah you
ever like that that was like well that
was where she got the idea from because
she had read about that kind of stuff
where you couldn't really experiment
even like medical students back in the
day had to kind of like they didn't like
the school didn't tell you hey go rob
some graves but they're kind of like
well you need a corpse to like
experiment on so we're not saying we're
to get it from or anything we're just
saying you need one that's our thing so
like a lot of said there was like that's
why there was like a big um you know
traffic and body snatching yeah that
went on for a long time because like
what else could you do you had to
experience yourself crack but back in
those days you [ __ ] saw dead bodies
weird [ __ ] you're selling this [ __ ] to
the doctors a tactical die got ya
[ __ ] have only 16 yeah yeah I mean in a
way it's like it sucks it sucks because
it was like it was horrible at the time
but like you can't really [ __ ] on it too
much because look at all the knowledge
that we got we talked about it in other
shows when you were lacking of bodies
you can create bodies to you just like a
Birkin here we need to do a show well
yeah they decided to cut out the middle
yeah on demand we're just yeah it's like
yeah what you what kind of body you need
yeah I'm gonna go kill some [ __ ]
people yes so you'd get like these
[ __ ] buboes as they called them which
is why it's called bubonic plague you
get them in you're like you know lymph
node areas you would also get like a
really bad fever you'd always got like
joint pain and stuff like that
now if left untreated and like I said
bubonic plague is still around although
in isolated pockets bubonic plague is
fatal between 30 and 75 percent of
people who get it often within 72 hours
so if you get it fast three days later
now there are other there are two other
types of plague pneumonic plague and
septicemia plague pneumonic plague being
more along kind of thing septicemia
flayed me more like a blood poisoning
type of thing but bubonic plague is
generally considered the the thing that
was probably like what was causing the
Black Death because several contemporary
writers did describe these huge
swellings like on the groin areas and
stuff like that there were several
writers that were run at the time that
kind of described what the [ __ ] looked
like so apparently so the the plague
that struck in Europe in the 14th
century there had already been some kind
of like shitty stuff happening before
that there had been an earlier plague
that had hit all their livestock and
also they had had crop failures from you
know over working the land
which happened a lot now they were on
there it also been two major famines
around Europe in 1316 and 1317 so that
didn't help there was also a couple of
Wars going on there was the Hundred
Years War which one I'm from between
1337 and 1453 and that was between
England and France in case you didn't
know also during this time period we
were going through what is known as the
Little Ice Age so environmental factors
probably played a a you know it was
probably a factor in why this became so
widespread now as I said the whole idea
of like a plague going through Europe it
was not like a new thing
there had been kind of a really bad
outbreak if that happened in the mid 50
which had gone through contests Noble
and the Mediterranean area however it
seems that the black death was kind of
like um you know not like a difference
in kind a bit like a difference in
degree so it seemed like a big huge
there was like a lot of factors like
contributing to making this a lot worse
than it was like I said climate [ __ ]
you know the way people were living at
this point and everything like that
yeah hygiene rating was the winter had a
lot to do with it no oh yeah no rodent
control at all yeah because like I said
no one knew that that's what was causing
it so it wouldn't occur to you to like
oh let's kill all the rats or let's try
to like make things more sanitary or you
know nowadays you know I'm not saying
that there couldn't be like a huge
outbreak of plague and nowadays because
obviously there could is like
particularly a flu that's like you know
an airborne virus but it wouldn't be
like this because one people know what
causes that now and two people would
know what measures to take three we have
the you know medical know-how to know
how to do some even asylum hygiene even
if it gets yeah even even if our medical
system gets overwhelmed
Dule people know yeah what it changed
like to kind of like you know minimize
your risk of getting that [ __ ] that's
you know that's it
you know I'm not saying that that's not
you know people might still get it
anyway but you know what I mean so the
the main outbreak of the black death
which like I said the main outbreak of
it which happened in 1347 probably came
via Sicily now historians have
pinpointed that there were four
particular ships that had come from
Genoa Italy and they were coming from or
they had come in to Genoa Italy from a
port called cava on the Black Sea and
that these four ships were probably the
source of the plague because these were
the ones that the rats had come off of
now these particular this particular
port city had been and we were talking
about this earlier the Mongols had
actually attacked this particular port
city with that whole like brick
catapulting like six dead bodies like
into your [ __ ] city into that so they
feel like this is probably like the the
Ground Zero of where the disease came
from now it could be - that the Mongols
like had come along the Silk Road like
just through regular trading routes and
had passed it to Europeans by those type
of means so you know like I said that
they've done genetic studies on it and
it does seem that it came from Asia
somehow but they're not entirely sure
where the exact point of you know the
exact point was where it came into
Europe mini-mini
location that's what I mean the time
it's kind of like a horrible thing and
it probably happened regularly because
they I'm sure they had a lot of I'm sure
they've sure trying to have a large
supply of plague-infested rats up there
in China well yeah and like I sang rides
and [ __ ] bugs you know because like I
said at that point in time in a large
part of China their lifestyle did not
was not conducive to
spreading disease to the same extent
that it would have been in Europe
because in Europe everyone was kind of
like living on top of each other I think
and living in unsanitary conditions you
know which they were not and everything
that I read it was always winners
involved when it got cold
the rats went under your house house for
warmth and when those rats started to
die off the the fleas had nowhere to go
but up the word bulwark and that
probably wasn't happening in China well
yeah like I said they didn't have the
same living condition oximeter maybe
they didn't even have houses that were
raised up off the [ __ ] floor so the
rats couldn't get underneath the damn
house the median some [ __ ] like that you
know it could be many things maybe it
never really quite got cold enough -
yeah - where the rats would concentrate
around people for warmth so maybe that
wasn't really happening in China we'll
never know we weren't there yeah but it
was gonna be something that simple yeah
and like I said it's in at this stage it
probably doesn't matter because they
know where the disease originated from
and they just know that at some point it
came into Europe and the living
conditions in Europe were very conducive
to it spreading to a great deal of
people in a very short amount of time a
lot of weird [ __ ] have it into this
society under these stresses I think we
covered that do we cover how this ended
it's it's odd because it didn't it
didn't end in the sense that I mean the
worst outbreak of it so many people died
it's like obviously the people that got
it and survived or the people that
didn't get it and survived for immune so
as it killed off all the people that
were susceptible to it it kind of like
eventually petered out just burned away
but for the next 300 years it kept
coming back look about every decade or
so like it would come back like not
obviously not to the great extent that
like that [ __ ] three four or five
year period yeah but it did keep coming
back and killing like
half a million people here half a
million people there my readings I
remember there was like three or four
major plagues there were each over a
period of a hundred some years but each
one of them was like half the size of
the one before yeah but it was still
enough and then eventually it just kind
of petered out and it's it's just kind
of a [ __ ] shows you have I don't
think that people have really changed
their lifestyle I think what it was the
disease itself was [ __ ] changing yes
it wasn't quite as deadly and and like I
said the thing happens where the disease
kind of ravages through a population and
it kills all the people that are
susceptible to it and the only people
that are left are immune to it right so
it that could happen with it with the
flu that's going around now and I think
it will and I think it'll happen pretty
fast that's what I mean that in about
five years
right any kind of problem that's why I'm
not super worried about it because yes
the virus viruses flu viruses in
particular like mutate very quickly but
you know humans kind of like develop
immunity kind of quickly as well
especially if they've been through like
sizing this year it seems to be like
five percent fatal next year it might be
only three the year after that I by the
way be one and a half you don't I mean
and then it gets why so it'll probably
just peter out like like the plague did
yeah and like I said as horrible as the
plague was you know and that killed like
I said you know obviously the population
in the world was much less back then but
the fact that it killed you know half
the people in your over 50% you know
over the of the population at the time
it's like yes that's bad but and that
thing has got to remember that this was
not a virus this was a [ __ ] bacteria
it was in and it's a it's a different
life cycle for a bacteria it's a lot
more complicated it wouldn't happen
today a virus is a lot easier to spread
you know well nowadays it is for sure
nowadays the way to go is virus because
the bacteriological ones like this are
easy for us to stop they just they won't
happen in the first place our houses
aren't built that way so that [ __ ]
right there stops a lot of it yeah and
to rodent control yeah yeah this is
another thing this is why don't worry as
much about yes I know that there's like
you know super bugs and there's like
viruses that are you know immune to
various you know medicines that we've
developed and vaccines that we've
developed and stuff like that and it's
like I know that that's a concern but I
mean just the fact that we realize you
know not only the difference between
bacteria viruses and different things
that cause diseases but also how do we
prevent this type of [ __ ] it's like it's
stupid but it's like cleanliness and
sanitation goes a long [ __ ] way
toward preventing yeah the majority of
this type of [ __ ] and you know there's a
lot of people were very modernistic they
want to live in [ __ ] dome to [ __ ]
super cities with everybody one on top
of the other and letting everything
letting [ __ ] suburbs [ __ ] vanish
and let everything return to the damn
wilderness there's a certain amount of
wisdom in the American Way of [ __ ]
life going way back to the 1700s we
lived a good clean living life here
because we valued low population density
spread the [ __ ] out spread the [ __ ] out
if you're spread the [ __ ] out it's just
nothing really well nothing can take
hold nothing can really take hold in you
it's not the same as a budget you know
Lukie hawking [ __ ] [ __ ] chinese
[ __ ] boomers in the damn subway
system one on top of another [ __ ]
coffin on one another that that [ __ ]
just doesn't happen
in most of America yeah we don't have a
[ __ ] Public Choice
it's weird because even in I mean even
in the United States even in large
densely packed cities like New York City
for example it's nothing like that well
because people are aware
yeah we have space bubbles even life
don't cough on people don't like it it's
like we're very aware of that even when
I lived in Boston after I got out of the
army it was taking the tea that tea is
not that packed yeah it's still a
[ __ ] civilized distance between one
another it's not like alright this [ __ ]
that I saw in Japan were you packing
them into them damn [ __ ] you know I
mean a [ __ ] subway like like sardines
inside of a damn subway train you know
that wasn't that wasn't happening in
Boston and we you know if I can I tell
you what as much as I'll [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know make fun of Boston [ __ ] you
know take the piss out of [ __ ]
Bostonians I like Boston in a way that
it was a it was during the time I was
there at least along the red line it was
a very civilized mass transit system it
was I'm every like mass transit system
that I've been on the United States I
have been even New York City it's like
yeah sometimes like some routes kind of
smell like pee but other than that not
too bad like not as bad as I was
expecting
DC's was actually quite nice I was
surprised Boston Red Line back in the
90s and I was there was kind of like
just going to the airport
it was nice yeah it's like most of the
time yes there are [ __ ] yes there
are this and then the other but it's
like I don't know I I guess because I
always kind of expect the worst from
people so I'm kind of like when people
are just like cool it's surprising and
I'm Greenline wasn't bad in that orange
line I'll tell you what that was rough
though it depends on the brows yeah yeah
yeah but yeah so like I said even though
the black death and bubonic plague
bubonic plague like I said is still
around they haven't eradicated it so it
does still recur at some like in
isolated pockets around the world even
to this day but the Black Death it's
kind of like the main outbreak of it was
kind of over by like 1352 or around
there but like I said for the next 300
years it kept recurring even in the 17th
century you know they'd still you'd
still have like five hundred thousand
people died from it
which is you know it sounds like not a
lot compared to like what who died from
like you know the initial outbreak but
it's still bad so it did still happen
for several hundred years afterward but
then it just eventually kind of like
petered out to like I'm manageable like
once they knew what caused it and began
to like you know clean [ __ ] up so it
wasn't like as prevalent which you know
now let's talk a little bit about the
1918 Spanish flu pandemic yeah
this is plague number three to give you
some context this one is I feel like a
lot of people maybe I don't I don't know
but like I feel like a lot of people
don't maybe know about this one even
though this was it was overshadowed by a
lot of kind of worse than the Black
Death I mean it killed more people I
think like in in terms of like relation
to what the population of you know I
don't think it was as brutal and his
[ __ ] nasty is the [ __ ] know just
because that was the medieval period and
they were liable a lot [ __ ] bodies
[ __ ] pile up in front of streets and
sanitation was bad and you know anyway
now there were a lot of mass burials and
it you know and then [ __ ]
superstitions going on in the Black
Death in this one people knew what
disease was and they were yeah and it
was orderly they were trying at least in
the United States their head there was
an organized effort to combat to not
spread it and to end to combat this and
to make sure people who were suffering
from it got some kind of care so maybe
they could recover and when they died
they were disposed of [ __ ] rapidly
yeah so this is a very different
cultural situation that an understanding
of what was going on although black
death was like something out of that
goddamn movie Excalibur yeah remember
that [ __ ] where their friend is you know
looking for the Holy Grail and I have to
say that well I think one of the factors
that contributed to the Spanish flu
being so fatal was that it occurred
while World War one was going on one I
think that helped it spread faster
because of
like troop movements around the world
and stuff like that and to I think it
also helped it spread faster because
because of the war there was so much
like particularly among the troops
because the first you know you know
cases of it showed up on like military
bases so I think that was because people
were malnourished they were stressed out
they were more likely to have their
immune system compromised and because
when they've done like genetic when
they've looked into like the genetic
background of this particular flu strain
it was actually not any worse than some
of the earlier ones that it happened but
it just it seemed to target more people
and particularly younger people which
was unusual for a flu strain but I think
that was because of the conditions of
the time you know like you had all these
young men living in trenches they were
all living very close together they
weren't you know someone that gets sick
and you wouldn't necessarily like
quarantine them it's like everyone was
kind of like packed close together and
was very stressed out you know they were
very malnourished so I think that there
was like some of that contributed to the
spread of it as well you would depend a
lot on on the personal point of view of
each person that was like in the country
I think if you were out in the middle
say like Mississippi back during this
time I don't think that this flu would
have even touched your life that much
but if you were living in a city like
Chicago or if I'm in New York maybe it
might have been a bigger
yeah because some of the cities at the
time like Philadelphia Boston and stuff
like that had huge it was a huge huge
impact goes back to what I just said a
minute ago you know I mean part of the
American lifestyle most of most of
America the low population density and
at this time you're talking about me
Barry going right out of handy Griffiths
show and and a [ __ ] you know I mean
a country lifestyle like that diseases
just don't spread as fast and I think a
lot of people we're living that way back
then so I don't think the I think they
knew about this disease but I don't
think it personally touched the average
person if you yeah this seemed like
mostly a disease that targeted military
bases in large cities yes so and another
thing is I don't think in this
particular pandemic I don't think there
was the same emotional impact because
you're talking about the age of science
and people being rational they knew what
it was well yeah they knew they
immediately recognized it was another
flu they knew what it happened well sure
so you're not dealing with [ __ ] the
same level of panic and super-state
where people are thinking of like it's
God's right God is like yeah sure yeah
even though the body count was higher I
kind of from everything I was able to
gather over the years about this one
people were pretty calm about it yeah
although like I said like the one
documentary that I watched that actually
talked to people that had lived through
it um I guess I didn't realize like the
extent of it because I kind of felt like
I mean I had heard of the 1918 Spanish
flu and I'll get into why it's called
space there was a whole EO academic -
that's what I mean there was a lot of
other epidemics going on at the time
because like I said this this was during
World War one which was it had like a
lot of young men they were living in
trenches for months at a time with not
really that great of food not really
that greatest sanitation it was like so
the spread of disease was like pretty
common so I feel like that might have
contributed to why this is kind of like
not yeah they were not talked about to
the same extent that like maybe the
blank says there's something too late
and sick and died and they just took
that for granted because that's what I
mean and and I do feel yeah I do feel
like even when they published like in
the papers when they would publish like
the deaths of
you know soldiers that have died in
World War one it's like they put like
the ones that had died in combat like
right next to the ones that had died
from flu even though the people that had
died from flu was like always like Ted a
hot do you know 1050 a hundred times
worse than the ones that had actually
died in combat mean more right yeah it
was like it was way more so I you know I
feel like say nothing about World War
one and World War one it's blowing up
into some weird ship World War one was a
weird [ __ ] war all right
a lot of those guys that died in World
War one in a way didn't die from direct
enemy action is more like indirect [ __ ]
artillery fire where it which is which
is weird maybe an ex infantry you know I
mean where they normally didn't see the
enemy just a shell would come in and
ball up yeah you know and it wasn't
really a war as I would know it was
mostly just like sitting around in a wet
trench bad conditions waiting for a
[ __ ] shell to hit you and like I said
Harvey I don't really fight more people
died from diseases they got just sitting
around in a trench lot waiting for shits
and the war I've said this before didn't
[ __ ] believe me but it is true and
[ __ ] you know a story and [ __ ] it
will back me up on this because that was
the ones that showed it to me a lot of
the [ __ ] literary and cultural
stereotypes about warfare about oh man
you know nobody likes war wars nothing
all wars this worse for just people that
sit there or whatever you know that
comes from world war one world war two
wasn't like that and neither was Korean
or Vietnam it's a very different you
know I mean but you always hear movies
and writers constantly going back and
recoating something that was referring
to world war one cuz that was the
[ __ ] yeah the Great War was one of
the worst wars it was from the point of
view of a [ __ ] saying if treatment on
the ground one of the least satisfying
Wars because you're out there in a war
in which you are never allowed to fight
it you just so you never get it out of
your system
really you sit there in a wet [ __ ]
trench waiting for a goddamn Shell to
hit you on the head and then if you went
over the top like they said you just get
mowed down by machine guns mm-hmm so you
never really fought any [ __ ] times
all right so that [ __ ] is oh that's
more psychological stress on a soldier
than it is out say in Vietnam kicking
somebody's [ __ ] ass and seeing dudes
and actually shooting and shooting them
you know in retaliation but what I'm
good waiting is always the word yeah
just sit around waiting you know sure
it's a lot easier just to have guys out
there killing each other that's that's
because that's that's something upfront
and honest
yeah because you know what the.oh know
what the [ __ ] going on and rather than
just like constantly wait brings out
Margit to happen yeah and you're
suffering and you don't know what's
gonna happen and there's not gonna be
anything gained because your army
doesn't have a technology to overcome
the enemy and they don't have a
technology so it's a constant stalemate
yeah and you just sitting there being
rained on and you and neither side is
gaining anything so of course super
demoralizing that was probably the most
inhumane and demoralizing war of all
times
and every documentary I say about this
just reinforces yeah that belief that I
[ __ ] read a lot of [ __ ] in books from
[ __ ] Patton and [ __ ] soldiers and
guys the whole [ __ ] series of [ __ ]
Band of Brothers is about my unit the
first in the 506 101st Airborne Division
most guys liked World War 2 they did
well they like it all there's a clear
you know you were fighting the Nazis got
work clearly yeah
bad guys yeah so there wasn't like a
moral gray area there wasn't like you
know I mean they're kind of was not to
the same extent afterwards you know they
found camps and then the Nazis became
even more demonized you know but really
what it was it was a real fight so you
could get it out of your [ __ ] system
yeah I mean yous didn't sit around
seeing your friends getting killed and
then you had no retribution
right you know but most guys that
actually fought World War two if you
look in the and you meet them like I did
because they would come and visit my
unit back when I was in the [ __ ] 506
m3 2/7 veterans from all the wars would
come and [ __ ] hey man I hadn't been
here in 30 they actually loved the fight
and most of the business I have heard
the same like World War two veterans
seem like a dim light I mean when you
like like I said I've seen documentaries
about World War one and you know we've
even seen documentaries about world one
veterans where they were talking and
stuff like that it seemed like a totally
different yeah you're always gonna have
some dude to get the shitty end of the
stick and you know I mean [ __ ] he got
killed as soon as he jumped out of the
[ __ ] boat but he's not around if I
can tell his tale but the guys that
survived all that usually for the
remainder of their lives that was the
high point of their life yeah they all
they did was [ __ ] tell ya the way they
talked about it it's gonna go to all the
reunions and everything that was the
centre of their identity and it was all
built when they were 18 whereas World
War one's you see one was a waste
everybody's like ya know it was always
because that seemed like the literal
worse it was I couldn't imagine that I
little I'd be pissed off his [ __ ] on a
mission like that and like I said I mean
considering the shitty conditions that
they had to put up with and then having
to put up with the Spanish flu outbreak
which killed way more people than the
fighting in Vietnam [ __ ] sucked
because basically the way that whole
system was set up is that you as an
infantryman will walk around like bait
waiting to get shot at so somebody else
could call in jets yeah have to kill you
so there was no lot most of the time
there was no real fighting the [ __ ]
enemy so your buddies died and you could
never really get revenge oh yeah you
felt like it was for now it was like it
was for nothing because you're just a
[ __ ] piece of cheese on the end and
the [ __ ] hook yeah as bait you know
so yeah Vietnam was mismanaged as
[ __ ] hell - the best wars of all
times World War two and the first Gulf
War and I was in service during the
first Gulf War
well there were reasons for yeah there
was clean cut in
out that's it [ __ ] okay we're done
and of course you know guys up top
wanted to make more money having a
forever war now let's go back to Iraq
there's more money to be made there all
these contracts yeah it's corrupt folks
it's a rigged system well obviously it's
a man's game yeah and like I said so
as if World War one wasn't shitty enough
he was this [ __ ] flu pandemic that
killed anywhere between 21 million and a
hundred million people you know what I
mean so and like I said it seems like
the conditions surrounding World War one
like contributed to why this spread so
quickly because there were so many
people because the the interesting thing
about Spanish flu is that normally flu
epidemics
they will kill X amount of people but
it's usually like babies or really old
people or people who are like
immunocompromised Spanish flu seemed to
kill more people that were like young
adults which was unusual but it could
have been that the reason that this
happened was one because young adults
were more susceptible to it because they
were the ones that were in the trenches
they were you know experiencing
malnutrition bad sanitary conditions etc
it could also be because there had been
a very bad flu outbreak in 1889 which
might have wiped out all the weaker old
people or the weaker people from
eighteen nine and them like my time 1918
rolled around the people that had
survived the flu in 1889 had immunity
you know when the 1918 one came around
so they were old then so it might have
been that they already had immunity
because they had already been through a
flu of that type yeah you know this flu
this flu is similar for right now it's
it's from what I remember it's similar
to the corona
terms of [ __ ] it is the how
contagious it is and the lethality yeah
I think most of them said it was this is
about between three and four percent of
fatal mm-hmm they're saying Coronas
about six so this is nice my ball I
think that the Spanish flu was ten or
maybe twelve depends on how they damn
juggled these numbers yeah but you have
to think you have to [ __ ] think when
Corona gets here will the situation on
the ground here in the United States or
Europe okay because we have a lot of
European and Austria will it be the same
as it was in the United States back in
the early nineteen thousand until you
know no I think it will be less lethal
than that well they go through cycles
and by the time I mean a virus can't
really survive outside of a host so it's
like the hosts that they go through are
affecting their genetic structure also
yeah so interactive right so that's the
thing if they kind of go through a lot
of people and it's kind of like well oh
something with today's technology you go
back in time to the [ __ ] Spanish flu
you're gonna save a lot more of them
yeah I mean Spanish flu killed the thing
about Spanish flu it and they're not
entirely sure where it started there
there are people that are arguing that
it started like that most of the
theories about where it started all on
military bases it was either a military
base in France or a military base in
Kansas they're not entirely sure where
the first case was but apparently some
dude turns up with like flu symptoms and
then like twelve hours later they're
dead and then the flu it spreads like
very very rapid leg like through this
particular army base and that it's sort
of spreading outward into and the the
shitty thing about it was that because
of the troop mobilization during World
War one you're putting all these troops
that
we're maybe asymptomatic in trains and
stuff like all close together and then
when they got to a new city like it
would just take one person and they
would spread it to all there's a lot of
populations a lot of different factors
that exist here in the United States and
in Europe today that might really affect
the mortality rate of a disease like
this if it were to happen again
air conditioning alone might affect it
like you know I mean like some of those
people that died a Spanish flu maybe if
they were in a hospital that was at 71
degrees Fahrenheit maybe they wouldn't
have died some of them wouldn't have
died yeah because you know they die
they're dying a fever yep
yeah not I mean and if you have them in
and outside like they did back then
intense at 90 degree weather a [ __ ]
high temperature and everything will
kill you a lot quicker if you were in a
[ __ ] city don't I mean versus say like
70 degrees so I think a lot of factors
have changed I think if the same disease
were to happen again in the United
States today the mortality wouldn't have
been as high as it was back in the early
nineties that's what I'm saying that's
what it's just for real simple that's
why don't worry about it as much because
I mean particularly the way we live
nowadays it's kind of like I'm not
saying that it couldn't spread to a lot
of people cuz it could obviously I think
it's very easy more of a moon cover but
yeah I do feel like because of the
awareness of it because of the way we
live because of the technologies that we
have I think it would be a lot less
lethal I think so too
then it would have a lot more I mean
whatever cover this is 1918 we're
talking about there was a lot of
differences back in 1980 yeah it's like
1918 they didn't have eighteen hundred's
they didn't have widespread air
conditioning they didn't have a like
they knew what was causing it like as
soon as they had isolated the virus they
recognized it as an influenza virus and
they also recognized as one that was a
that was a different strain and that was
a more virulent strain so they did
recognize
that even in 1918 so they did know hey
don't go around sneezing on people hey
so like they did like warm people about
like please wear masks and stuff like
that even there's videos of you know
when the armistice was declared you know
the First World War
you can see like all the parades and
stuff like that that happened at
everybody had masks on and that's
because of the of this [ __ ] flu but
they did like warm people about doing
that so they so they weren't as clueless
yeah but even back then there was
there's even back then with the
knowledge that they had there's still a
huge improvement with today oh yeah I
mean today well now we can like it
within a day or two you can well you can
do a genome sequence on even it's even
small smaller [ __ ] today you might have
a bunch of [ __ ] nurses running around
a sick ward with a bunch of people with
this corona virus telling people to
trick water and back then maybe they
didn't maybe just D height maybe a
certain amount of dehydration alone
killed a certain percentage of them I
mean there's a lot of different a lot of
little small things can add up to make a
difference yeah
air conditioning proper hydration
telling it rolling dudes over on their
sides or [ __ ] turning them in another
directions think off [ __ ] fluid out
of their lungs you know I mean there's
just all those little things can kind of
add up yeah Dave you know yeah and like
even though it might not save like one
individual person but overall because
like you know like I said it as you know
our knowledge is constantly progressing
and it's like yeah we don't know
everything and [ __ ] like that but we
know like an exponential about like yeah
more stuff than they knew back in the
medieval era or even in 1918 so we know
a lot more than they knew we can't go
back to 1918 to see exactly what the
nurses were doing on the ground and all
these huh right they might have been
[ __ ] like I said I'm telling people
to lay on their damn
some lay still yes kill somebody it
could yeah yeah I mean oh no don't let
him cuff all that up ya know it seems
like not a big deal but it is a baby a
little bitty things can make a big
difference
like nobody thought that washing your
hands was a big deal but that's one of
the main things that prevents you
spreading things to other people is
constantly washing your hands I'm trying
to minimize this [ __ ] outbreak
respect it though respect it yeah but
like it's it's the kind of thing where
it's like you know it's out there and
it's like you know if that means that
you wash your hands a few more extra
times or you you know master's wear a
mask when you go out or something or you
stay at home where you might not have
it's like that might make a huge [ __ ]
difference on the average when you're
dealing with [ __ ] millions of people
right because it's like if you're just
one person and you have it and you go
out somewhere where there's like
hundreds of people you could potentially
right spread that I mean it's very easy
that it could happen yeah and if you do
catch it chances are you'll survive it
but also chances are you'll spread it
then you'll give it to somebody else and
some of those yellow might on average at
least in China for other people yeah I
think probably in a place like United
States on average and probably at least
half that yeah in some ways it's like
you have to adopt a you know a measure
of you know where you're feeling like
well yeah it sucks for you to get sick
you don't want to get sick but also try
not to spread it to others you know what
I mean so it's like if you're sick
please stay home like and if you have in
here you know now that everybody knows
what this is and we're living in the
modern world you might have hundreds of
thousands of [ __ ] Americans here or
Australians or New Zealand foot that
have it but they every one of them knows
that they shouldn't spread it
yeah and in Prior ages they didn't even
have that concept oh yeah there's a I'm
just gonna breathe that everybody is not
gonna take hold I don't think that's why
I don't worry about stuff as
much now as because I China's gonna get
the worst of it they are and and I
always kind of feel like because I know
about because I know about Spanish flu
because I know about black deaths
because I know about that kind of stuff
and it's like you know coming from a
point of view of not knowing what was
causing it and not knowing what was
spreading it it's like now that we know
that it's like yeah everybody might not
do it all right you got that [ __ ]
already we both been coughing I have
well I think that just went down the
wrong way but you know coming from a
point of view at least we know that you
have to like wash your hands you have to
like not try - don't touch - like don't
touch her don't touch like doorknobs and
[ __ ] like that or you know what I mean
you kind of want to avoid congested
areas for a little while yeah but at
your own discretion like I said just
because you catch this it's not really
here in the u.s. right now to speak up
but just because you catch this doesn't
mean you'll die from it most people
won't that's what I mean it's like
that's why I'm not super worried about
it because it's like yes it's a flu it's
like I am just inclined to entreat it
like to treat it like any other flu
where it's kind of like it sucks to get
it but you're probably not gonna die
from it just try to not give it to other
people and you know try to just stay in
your house and don't you know I mean
because like I said you know any dangers
not from the disease itself as the
effects of the disease oh yeah and like
I said I feel like that kind of habit it
wasn't that buy me the Spanish flu
considering how many people had killed
the social impact of it was bad but it
was far less than the Black Death say
which kind of caused a whole like
seismic [ __ ] change in the whole
social structure and I'm gonna say
America as a whole understands the
impact of this and you got guys that
work from the Power Company and the
Water Company and people that drive
trucks I don't think that I don't think
they're just gonna bug out that that
easily I think they're just gonna go to
work with masks on yeah [ __ ] going
because they know that if they don't go
to work as a group they could collapse a
damn society so I kind of think what
will probably happen is is that once it
starts up in the United States people
will just hold together and know this
[ __ ] power through it
that's why though masks and [ __ ] you
know try to avoid from getting sick
that's what I said I'm that's why I'm
not super worried about it cuz like
they're they're psychologically prepared
and as much as you know people like to
piss and moan about how self-centered
people are I do feel like people
nowadays are more aware of how their
actions impact others which maybe they
weren't back in the old days and as you
know is a panic set in
yeah and that and panicking is like the
worst thing that can have thats always
bad if you ask me china's panicking
these parts of china right it's but in
some ways like if it's bad a little bit
of panic is justified because it's like
if that means like a whole bunch of
people in this city have it and we knew
like close outs it even like not let
people go in or leave then okay then
that's justified but everyone doesn't
need to freak out about [ __ ] because
that never leads to anything how did the
Spanish flu and the weird thing about it
is no one really knows it's like so many
people died from it like I said there
was like [ __ ] it went through the
u.s. I think the u.s. um I've seen
estimates everywhere from 550,000 to
like 750,000 people like it killed a lot
more people in Europe and stuff like
that but some cities Philadelphia Boston
and stuff like that were kind of closed
down for a little while and you know
that was kind of like a big thing about
it it mostly spread a lot on military
three bases and then it kind of like
spread to other to civilian populations
and as I said it killed at least as many
as the Black Death if not more and you
have to think that the population of the
world in 1918 was only about 28% of what
it is now so something like this
happening nowadays would mean that like
375 500 million people then so that's
what the equivalent would be so you know
it it [ __ ] [ __ ] up for a while but not
as long as the Black Death did because
like I said nowadays I mean even in 1918
they knew what was causing it they knew
how to prevent it they knew so and a few
years later World War 2 was hidden and
they were kicking ass like nothing ever
happened right so like I said even
though it was like you know a shitty
thing that happened a lot of people died
from it like I said it killed a lot more
people than died in the actual war I've
read some estimates where it killed more
people than where will run in World War
two combined and maybe even Vietnam and
similar horrors in there too like it
killed like millions of millions of
people so it's nothing to sneeze at you
know but it just seems like it the
impact the far-reaching impact of it
wasn't quite as drastic as maybe
something that happened in the Middle
Ages and like I said I feel like as you
know as as as we go on and we get more
you know scientifically like we know
what what these viruses are where they
come from what causes them you know even
if we don't have a cure for them because
like I said we're still going through I
mean technically we're still going
through an AIDS pandemic
even though you don't see a lot of it in
the United States anymore because a lot
of it's been managed like you know
through drugs and things like that so a
lot of people don't die from it in the
United States anymore but you still see
you like in sub-saharan Africa there's
like I still a lot of people like
millions people still dying from it but
it's like you don't really see the same
impact
because we have that understanding and
at least I mean we were watching the
Netflix series there's a Netflix series
called pandemics and I've only seen like
the first couple episodes well it's you
know it's pretty good but I have to say
that there are some people out there I
mean there's one guy in particular who
him and is like his assistant or
whatever they're kind of like trying to
and they've tried to get money from like
Bill Gates Foundation and everything
like that where they're trying to
develop a universal flu vaccine because
they're kind of like looking forward to
a time when you know it's like we need
to immunize everyone against any flu
vaccine that can mutate or come along or
anything like that and they're doing it
on their own dime and they're doing it
in the sense that we don't want to do
this for money we just want everyone to
have this just so we don't have a
[ __ ] global pandemic so like I said
there are some people out there working
on this yeah some superheroes don't wear
capes as they say and I feel like we
will get to that point where shit's
gonna happen
people are gonna die but like I said I
don't know if you're gonna see something
like the Black Death yeah or even the
Spanish flu in 1918 I don't know if
we're gonna see that again so what can
you do about this this is my this is my
advice consider this to be something
about like a hurricane or Hurricane
Katrina we got hurricanes here every
year we've got a hurricane season all
right yeah so I'm gonna consider it just
like a hurricane but if you wanted
November 30th right what you do is is
over the next couple weeks throw back
some extra food something that's
shelf-stable rice beans canned food
whatever okay also throw back some fresh
water maybe buy a couple you know a
bunch of cases of them little [ __ ]
waters maybe a one of those big ol jugs
of water that you get from the
like in a water machine but the office
something like that just some fresh
water and then get you some [ __ ]
extra toilet paper okay this is a shelf
we were talking about the shelves go dry
won't be shitty things are running after
you get actually you know what else a
bit would be good is to have some kind
of way to filter water that way if you
ever lost water because the water
partment guys didn't work out it's a
hurricane type situation you can collect
rainwater in your area or whatever dirty
water and you can filter it there's a
bunch of different also get a grill and
some propane yeah but a lot of some
people might be living in a you know
find some way to cook if power goes like
I said you need to wit you at least you
know way to boil water if you're already
power right i we I've been through many
I'm from Florida I was born here so it's
like ever here they were used to this
[ __ ] they give us this hurricanes bail
if you could find a little propane
burner for flower stem that would work
if you have a big propane bottle to run
that [ __ ] little barn or even better
so that's your food and water and your
toilet paper okay it's very important
the next thing on top of that would be
like maybe like some kind of mask of
gloves and goggles so that's in case you
ever have to go out alright but I don't
really think that's all that important
really but but that would be a good
thing to have and you can research
there's we have it we have a subscriber
named weapons and stuff that's a channel
on YouTube and he gets all into that
with masks what kind of masks you can
buy gloves you know any kind of glove
and maybe some goggles and sometimes the
mask and the goggles is one things
that's it that way if you go out to go
resupply or to buy stuff you don't get
affected the Japanese been doing it
forever okay with a little mass and so
the Chinese if you live in an area where
you think [ __ ] it might go bad you
might
invest as some means to defend in that
food because if you look to what
happened in Hurricane Katrina people who
are unprepared don't have any food
they'll only go about three days without
food and water before they'll attack
somebody else to get their food and
water because you're starving you know
nine meals you missed nine meals you
become dangerous especially if you've
got kids or a family to feed so you
might want to miss some way of defending
that and I don't know what country
you're in you know if you're in the UK
you came in on Dec goddamn butter knife
guns and clubs you can't have a gun get
clubbed that's that would be what I
would say stay indoors lay low yeah
that's all worst case scenario [ __ ]
though that's what I mean that's the
most really worried about that yet no
it's like like I said if I had been to
China had been something it's like I'm I
don't know like I said I'm not worried
about it right now it's like I'm still
yeah going out and doing [ __ ] it's like
you know we have enough food here we
have a generous case scenario 90 days
even 60 days would be a worst-case
scenario
real common a couple weeks a month yeah
but it's always good to have 90 days
where the [ __ ] well if you're but anyway
even anyway for any reason you can eat
it anyway that's what I mean it's it's
not like it's going to waste waste no
because we kind of always have that [ __ ]
anyway because of like hurricanes
because we've had like hurricanes hit we
had power out for yeah so we have a
generator stuff so it's not like that
weird extra window units to keep the air
conditioner going cuz you know you know
how white folks aren't gonna get hot
that's not how it is man yeah I'm not
having it not here man not in this heat
and humidity [ __ ] no Florida at Florida
bro this is Dagobah if you're watching
this is very lorna and they love it but
it's like yeah have you ever lived here
it's really not fun yes oh it really
says
and I was born here I wanted Daytona
Beach and it's like I'm still and I
still hate it modern houses and modern
buildings here in the United States are
not built to be without air-conditioning
two days later they all just [ __ ]
smell like mold everything just stink
just starts to stake the carpets just
start [ __ ] say if it as soon as that
temperature goes above [ __ ] 85 80 and
the humidity the humidity here is always
a hundred percent pretty much it's just
everything starts to rot and a mold
there they're just meant to be kept at
about 71 degrees Fahrenheit just just
presume if you're going to move to
Florida everything is like a huge
open-air sauna yeah almost the entire
year
yeah like in the winter you get like
maybe a month or two of reprieve yeah
but the rest of the year it feels like
you're in a sauna except you can't yeah
so wrap up food water water filtration
some kind of means to cook things I
means to defended that mask goggles
that's really all you'll be fine
seriously it's like I hire minimum like
I said I'm not worried about this cuz
like I said we had [ __ ] stars that
happened like ten years ago and everyone
was freaking out about that and it's
like I'm just treating it like it's a
hurricane yeah which is probably like
the healthiest way to look at it because
you don't know if a hurricane is gonna
like we've had hurricanes hit I've had
hurricanes no power because that was
powerful months I've lived here longer
than you have up as long as you've lost
power eight days it was a witch it
sucked bite walk I lived eight days of
that power here at manna and it was in
August he's going back to [ __ ]
Dagobah you you use it long as you and
Yoda oh yeah I try not to think about it
it was a it's like yeah every I was just
like sweaty hot muggy stinky all the
time can't [ __ ] sleep here no without
a case well when our AC was out we had
to fill the bath
with ice and can lay in the tub and then
get cool and then sleep in like shifts
yeah because it's - you can't sweat cuz
the humidity is 100% that's what I mean
it's like humans have evolved like this
wedding thing yeah but this wedding
thing doesn't work when the humidity is
it your your sweat can't evaporate no it
just seems like it just sits there feels
like you're wrapped in a damn plastic
bag and then a big old [ __ ] hot wet
carpet wrapped around you yeah like all
the time yeah all the time so this is
why I know playing outside is better
than being inside but you go outside
then but [ __ ] mosquitoes eat you up
that's it you can't go outside and then
you'll get in cephalic yeah Florida it's
special it's yeah it's actually a
paradise when everything's working it's
just that Florida's not supposed to be
here it was it was dead to here this
forced Florida is like a swamp that we
decided that we were gonna colonize this
so we like built stuff on it but we have
to build stuff but if you go outside for
any length of time you'll realize that
this is not free it's not for human
habitation alligators it's not for us
we're not supposed to be here I've
barely even like riding my motorcycle
anymore now I go that's what I mean and
I still try to do like my you know my
power walks and stuff like that but it's
like in the summer I have to go very
very early in the morning and even then
it's whoo it's kind of nasty and then
I'll come back and it's like even the
wintertime I come back and I'm just like
you have like a [ __ ] swamp ass and
[ __ ] I just think old pasta Leone was
over here trudging around here back in
the 15 hunters looking for the damn
Fountain of Youth I can't imagine I
can't imagine like [ __ ] what yeah
that's what I mean it's like every time
I read about like for the history and
stuff and like all the [ __ ] spot and
Spanish conquistadors they came here
it's like why would they come here that
you would think they would come here and
be like [ __ ] this [ __ ]
yeah I'd be like out of here [ __ ]
hell
especially and this is just Central
Florida like South Florida's like I
thought [ __ ] was so funny when was it
named Karl Benjamin that guy from
[ __ ] his channel so it was a sargon
of akkad he [ __ ] went to Disney
Disney World up the road here and he
[ __ ] stuffed outside of his damn
[ __ ] hotel room on the balcony and he
was I can't believe it this is like
Satan's ass crack and I was like welcome
to my world one of the record I was born
here this yeah there any pants out over
the [ __ ] swamp that yes Disneyland
Disney World is in a [ __ ] swamp it
was this one it was a [ __ ] swamp hey
[ __ ] Saint built
Disney World opened y'all in 1972 the
same year I was born but prior to that
Orlando was a swamp area
yeah like the Everglades yeah so they
basically purposely we're gonna build
this [ __ ] here because the land was
cheap was worthless yeah and it was
worthless for a reason and then they
just like had to so they had to like
build everything like on top of the [ __ ]
but like humans were not supposed yeah
and now that I look there's luxury
hotels with the international clientele
in the middle of [ __ ] swamp is
[ __ ] hilarious when you think about
it it is beautiful though it is it's a
beautiful it's just [ __ ] it's
beautiful to look at from photographs a
window
yeah from with this idea air-conditioned
because if you go outside you'd be like
whoa although I have I will note that I
have I have known people from the UK
that came here on vacation
never somebody loved [ __ ] [ __ ] they
loved how hot it was that's cuz then I
was like you alright because they only
put up with it for a few days
cause they're only here for a week or
two but you know I mean it was live here
your whole life it's really not I mean
the entire summer like like I said I was
born in Central Florida so the summer
time was kind of like you would go into
the house like and you would just sleep
by the air-conditioner wherever it was
in your house because I grew up in a
house that didn't have central air it
just had like a window unit I can't
understand it
so yes how did you survive that [ __ ] um
I slept in the dining room
hotter than Mississippi here yeah even I
just slept in the dining room I I put
out like my grandmother because I stay
in my grandmother's house she would put
like a quilt like a palette yeah in the
lip in the little living room that was
right by the Dyer room where the air
conditioning unit was and you would just
everyone just sleep in there yeah
because you couldn't sleep in the
bedrooms
yeah it's no job in the summer we lost
AC and you couldn't I couldn't focus it
I had to get out of the bed go on the
floor remember that yeah you can't
it's just careful you can't sleep
because it's just kind of it's not only
hot it's just the humidity and this yeah
it's just like it's a smell and it's
like the wetness it's just like pushing
into your face also ridges yeah
everything smells rotten and all of a
sudden everything smells like [ __ ]
Dagobah and the inside smells worse than
the outside just that bacteria just
[ __ ] eat up everything here's the bad
well and even if you have air
conditioning you constantly constantly
have to be on the lookout for mold in
your house also termites yeah
termites will eat your we're born them
this Raptors [ __ ] show up all right
so I gave you the advice don't
underestimate it don't breathe on people
to do put I would recommend to prepare
for at least just basic preparations
well it worried like you would do any
kind of [ __ ] don't freak out about it or
anything the army would call it [ __ ]
paper gets my [ __ ] paper okay because
imagine if you couldn't wipe your ass
because you couldn't buy any more toilet
paper just in case it really does seem
like something that people in the West
don't really think about because you
always have toilet paper but then when
you don't have it well would go upside
world would go upside down if you can I
have to wipe your boat with your hand go
ahead and wash your hand really good and
then all the rest of the day every time
you touch something with that hand
you're gonna be thinking about I just
wiped my ass with that you know I washed
it and then
if you you know you you lost power and
water and toilet paper he'd be [ __ ]
pretty much yeah it's funny because I
was out of pack when we have that hurt
well we had four hurricanes in quick
succession several years ago and our
power was out for quite a long time and
all I remember I remember it being very
hot I remember eating a lot of pop-tarts
because that was pretty much like a cold
pop tart but I guess we had enough
toilet paper because I don't remember
running and enjoy the paper I'm what
kickback like two extra cases of toilet
paper at all time yeah we need to make
the big [ __ ] things it's that way
you'd have like two months of twelve
that paper always at all times that's
probably good yeah I'm probably more
worried about toilet paper than food no
I can live with that food I like to add
protein brother wrap this [ __ ] up I'm
your bro yeah bro I've been drinking
we're drunker than usual I feel like
well you know we're drunker than usual
yeah yeah we're kind of that's okay it's
Saturday it's Saturday night
that's just got the show down early
though it's probably nine o'clock no
it's ten twelve no really it is
look there's the clock right there okay
all right so this was our show kind of
vaguely about Pistons kind of was yeah
um so you know be careful out there you
know I'm not worried about it
he's worried about it yeah if you like
to show me subscribe like a subscribe
like it too like it give us some likes
and subscribe and hit us up on patreon
we could always you know man if you
wanted we have the more shows we have
then Jenny's can [ __ ] Jenny can do
all the research and we can continue on
it's gonna be all good then she can't
present I don't get any of this money
it's all Jenny well cuz I'm the one
doing you're the one just laying in
there I go what's this I was like I told
you it's about pandemic oh yeah
that dish on five minutes just on the
record you started to your wisdom man
that's right means it's always this is
all real this is real is wisdom man he
seriously doesn't even of the topic
before life I ever stop it no I dunno
stop it so sometimes sometimes I even
study for the topic sometimes sometimes
it depends on how to have meticulous the
topic is yeah my job is my job is to be
the [ __ ] audience yes and and you
know I mean to [ __ ] [ __ ] up my job is to
[ __ ] [ __ ] up my [ __ ] is my job was
always the [ __ ] [ __ ] up that's why they
hired me breaking breaking [ __ ] you know
man yeah so we did and then my job is to
like do all the like figure out all the
topics your intellectual man is research
all the time electrolysis and then try
to bring him back to the topic wildly
off it's a spot Kurt dynamic it is yeah
you love me just like just like Spock
and Kirk love each other you think there
was some gay gave us some gala going on
even if it wasn't I'm shipping that okay
I'm shipping that [ __ ] love old Star
Trek my favorite well Spock is like
probably one of my favorite fictional
characters ever so it's like when people
cuz you know my ex-husband I got my
Spock too but it's like I was he meant
it as an insult
yeah what I was not insulted all of
those characters from the original
series were cool I like tomorrow bones
was rad - yeah they were all cool I
liked him because he was there cranky
because I'm kind of cranky and once next
generation started to roll and you know
rough around the third season I got into
that but I was also a big fan of [ __ ]
enterprise you liked enterprise like oh
didn't like enterprise I'm a [ __ ]
slap in the face of my dick Enterprise
enterprise is one of the best of all
Star Trek's is very underrated with
Archer the first season wasn't all that
great it took a while to find its
footing I was I'll tell you what man it
had two of the best
episodes of all [ __ ] times where they
go back and they still call you yeah
there's still this stole they went back
to get the thali incident [ __ ] tied
in with the loss of the Defiant from
[ __ ] the original serie I didn't like
that one yeah and okay if you guys don't
want to know what [ __ ] an arranger
style unit is or a hardcore Tim Friede
just watch me webs called in a mirror
darkly one and two that's the way the
Army is it's exactly a good army good
army is just like the mirror episode
[ __ ] were ruthless
I did like ruthless yet we watched like
the whole enterprise like I'm um I'm
more like a original series fan
yeah I like it do you have to say my
favorite I like to stop and like I like
that one continues with well yeah Star
Trek continues was the fan go we did
some we did a show on it we did yeah we
did a reveal vic Mignogna [ __ ] did
and his team did a great job on reef on
the
Wow another see they captured the theme
that and the iPhone of the original
search that is Star Trek and he is one
of the best Kirk's he's the second there
are two Kirk's well there's really only
one Kurt and that's [ __ ] the shat
this [ __ ]
that's Kurt but Vic's Kirk - I'm just
and I mean I'm kind of like one of those
people that it's like ah man don't try
to like [ __ ] but you know that they
did do a really and it's a free it's a
free season right there on on youtube
check out Star Trek continues if you
like the originals if you like the
originals yeah and I enjoyed it when I
first heard about this what the [ __ ] is
this is it's a fan made it in like I
know people are like wow but now it's so
good yeah you see it you go oh no this
is seriously the last episode I do I do
yeah I cried the dude who played Scotty
is played by Scotty son his son yeah
[ __ ] that's got like an all-star cast
two [ __ ] guests show up like [ __ ]
Lou Ferrigno shows up in
yeah [ __ ] Buck Rogers what was her
name I mean Erin gray hair and gray
shows up in it and it's just too cannon
it's like [ __ ] cannon
they were very [ __ ] Star Trek well
the cool thing about the cool thing
about that show was that they he took
like the episodes that he liked the most
and he's like I want to like continue
this story and that's what that's what
he did with each episode he's kind of
like I want to like see what happened
right like after this episode and like
expand on that and I think that was like
a really good yeah like the mirror
episode would the evil Spock with the
[ __ ] evil goatee mustache Fox he
actually did a part to just and it's
[ __ ] oh man it's awesome I've like
Spock did after Kirk went back I like
that was probably my favorite one yeah
because Spock is my favorite yeah and
and Todd haberkorn plays Spock in that
and he's a good Spock I eat you Leonard
Nimoy is [ __ ] almost near impossible
to follow he invented that care case
[ __ ] Spock sorry
so the first 10 20 minutes you like I'll
come on man this isn't Leonard Nimoy but
then you're like no this is pretty cool
it's a yeah and like a couple episodes
later you go like yeah this Spock and
then [ __ ] like another episode they
like yeah it's [ __ ] spot yeah you you
you da pew yes sir all that I mean but
[ __ ] Vick as [ __ ] Captain Kirk
immediately you're like that's [ __ ]
Captain Kirk yeah you're like yeah
that's Captain Kirk he really does
embody that character yeah I mean like I
said it's harder for me to get behind
somebody that Spock's biggest [ __ ] is my
favorite but um Leonard Nimoy is come
yeah but but Todd did a good job but he
did yeah he was really good and that
that like says a lot for me to say that
I'm not like a total star Sharky but I
really didn't like the original singer
we still got to finish the movies I got
all the [ __ ] movies with the original
that we only got we got to do what was
it episode movie three search for Spock
we haven't seen that one yeah yeah we
did know we watched that one we've Sam
watch the
fourth one we didn't watch the one with
the whales that search force pocket in
it no okay I gotta go back there to look
at it back because yeah that's right
search of Spock addendum of the whale
that was the one with the planet like it
was like a kid named the one with with
the whales [ __ ] number four journey home
yeah yeah yeah yeah we watch that worse
if we brush the verse three yeah journey
home but I've seen them all but I have
to but it's like I don't remember man I
gotta make a [ __ ] model I want to
make one of those [ __ ] Klingon battle
cruisers with the and I'm gonna put the
fiber-optic cables to make the lights
Goins and like something straight out of
the goddamn movies I can make a model I
can make bottles I want to make a
[ __ ] Klingon model Klingon [ __ ]
battle core is it okay junk is fit junk
is [ __ ] I don't think you'd be able to
do it as drunk no not right now okay you
could do it say I want to do the one out
I want to do the the the battlecruiser
out of [ __ ] Star Trek the motion
picture okay that way okay did we say
already that like you should like share
subscribe also check out our new
Instagram which is 13 o'clock podcast
that'd be me also what's your thing
called just Tom Ross yes I'm a bunch of
numbers
yeah well and also if you look on 13
o'clock podcast be on there and you go
to like the the things that I've been
tagged in or whatever yeah I'll be on
because he's posted a bunch of pictures
of him and made that you know so you can
kind of like retro actively get back to
it so yeah and if you would like to
financially support the show
that'd be much appreciated go to our
patreon page patreon.com/lenguin
there's a button in the sidebar to a
PayPal account if you would like to give
a one-time donation any donation no
matter how small would be much
appreciate it and helps us make the show
better so you know you want to do that
please do it hopefully you guys enjoyed
episode 183 kind of about pandemic
it's about pendennis we mean kinda don't
get sick okay we're her mask do all that
[ __ ] we will see you next time bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]